Figaro live un petit peu plus de 15h20
maintenant merci merci d'être avec nous
en direct pour suivre et commenter le
premier meeting de campagne du président
candidat Emmanuel Macron ça a lieu en ce
moment à la défense Paris
Arena à Nanterre dans les Hauts-de-Seine
les équipes du candidat ont promis un
rendez-vous spectaculaire alors nous
allons voir ça nous allons voir ce qu'il
en est dans quelques instants je suis un
plateau avec Frédéric Michaud bonjour
Frédéric Michaud qui va commenter
décrypter avec nous tous les enjeux de
ce meeting Frédéric Michaud vous êtes
donc déjà adjoint d'Opinion Way et nous
avons une équipe sur place Vincent
roseron et Riad Becker qui qui est en
compagnie de François-Xavier bourneau
grand reporter au service politique du
Figaro et qui suit notamment l'Élysée et
donc la campagne du président sortant du
président candidat Vincent roseron c'est
à vous
[Musique]
oui bonjour brune on est effectivement
direct dans cette
u Arena de Nanterre chez François qui
avait bourreau Xavier ce meeting à quoi
à quoi on peut s'attendre déjà pour ce
midi il faudra appeler le seul meeting
du premier tour d'Emmanuel Macron oui
Emmanuel Macron là il est lance
véritablement sa campagne pour l'instant
ça patine ça a été compliqué pour lui et
donc là aujourd'hui il veut réaliser une
démonstration de force c'est une chose
d'assez spectaculaire pour montrer qu'il
peut mobiliser autour de autour de lui
et que ça s'accompagne nos [ __ ] pas
dans la choucroute comme on en a un peu
l'impression depuis le depuis le début
c'est compliqué toujours pour un
président sortant de se remettre dans la
campagne de retourner sur le terrain de
revêtir les habits du candidat là ils
ont organisé l'événement donc assez
spectaculaire on voit sans doute
derrière nous ils ont quasiment rempli
le le la défense la défense Arena et
donc Emmanuel Macron va se poser en
majesté ça c'est pour le c'est pour la
forme réussir à meeting et montrer qu'il
peut rassembler autour de lui un peu
comme tous ses concurrents l'ont fait
mais eux depuis le début de la pré
campagne en dernier donc là on entre
dans la dernière semaine c'est un enjeu
d'abord de mobilisation qui a priori a
l'air à la réussite pour l'instant non
faut voir si Emmanuel Macron va réussir
à tenir la salle en tout cas parce
qu'elle est très grande elle a l'air
très très animée c'est pas forcément le
le plus simple et surtout à
Emmanuel Macron sera au centre avec un
octogone et à l'intérieur il sera face à
la foule qui lui fera face de toute part
en fait oui il sera le seul à prendre la
parole aujourd'hui c'est une volonté
délibérée est-ce que c'est le candidat
qui enfin que le parti allait mais tous
ces alliés veulent mettre en majesté si
on peut dire il y a une sorte de petite
animation qui est prévue avant
avec des quelque chose d'interactif avec
la foule de diffusion de de clip un
espèce d'animation digitale un tifo
d'après ce que j'en ai compris des
fumigènes enfin tout est fait pour
mettre en valeur le le candidat et
surtout ce que va dire le candidat parce
que il s'est exprimé déjà sur son
programme mais ça ressemblait plus à un
discours de mi-mandat ça a pas suscité
ou soulever beaucoup de beaucoup
d'enthousiasme là maintenant l'enjeu
pour lui dans la dernière ligne droite
qui mène au premier tour c'est donc de
montrer de la mobilisation autour de lui
et surtout de développer quelques
propositions nouvelles susceptibles de
le le mettre au centre des des
discussions et en tout cas d'écraser un
peu la mauvaise polémique qui monte
autour de lui sur la ferme à kinssey
l'idée c'est d'arriver à créer à se
recréer une dynamique et installer aussi
un duel face à Marine Le Pen comme il
voulait le faire depuis très longtemps
oui voilà ce que l'ordre d'arrivée au
premier tour de dimanche prochain va
être très importante c'est là où on va
où on va voir si Emmanuel Macron fait
mieux qu'en 2017 si Marine Le Pen
réussit à élargir son socle électoral de
premier tour donc l'enjeu c'est vraiment
d'arriver en première position au
premier tour dimanche prochain pour
pouvoir enchaîner sur la campagne de
deuxième tour qui là sera une campagne
totalement différente dimanche prochain
c'est une autre campagne qui commence et
pour la rentrée bien dans cette campagne
là il faut réussir le premier tour
réussir le premier tour pour Emmanuel
Macron ça veut dire mobiliser et surtout
essayer de creuser un peu l'écart par
rapport à son son premier concurrent qui
pour l'instant est donné dans les
sondages comme étant Marine Le Pen ou en
tout cas montrer que le qui a plus une
dynamique en sa faveur quand sa faveur à
elle on voit qu'elle qu'elle bouge
beaucoup enfin que ça ça frémit beaucoup
pour Marine Le Pen dans cette dernière
ligne droite l'enjeu pourrait Emmanuel
Macron c'est en tout cas pas de pas se
faire coller voir de la distance
effectivement on voit derrière nous les
drapeaux qui sont agités on a vu des
clapping une banda qui est en train de
jouer il essaie d'avoir de l'ambiance
pour ce petit on l'a dit une seule prise
de ma parole celle d'Emmanuel Macron
mais tous ces soutiens sont là on a vu
par exemple Édouard Philippe qui est
présent oui c'est un vrai défilé là de
de soutien qu'on a vu en coulisse alors
il y a il y a eu François Bayrou il y a
eu Jean-Pierre Chevènement Eric Woerth
l'ancien l'ancien LR il y a Édouard
Philippe Bruno Le Maire enfin tout le
bon et l'arrière bande de la majorité
aurait été mobilisés pour assister à ce
meeting c'est une image d'unité qui doit
être renvoyé aujourd'hui
avec toute la majorité d'Emmanuel Macron
derrière lui dire qu'on oublie un moment
les les petites querelles ou les les
fortes tensions qu'il y a pu avoir
pour prendre le pas ou devenir l'homme
puissant de la prochaine majorité
l'enjeu là c'est vraiment d'afficher
derrière derrière et Emmanuel Macron le
rassemblement c'est une image qu'on
avait pas eu l'occasion de beaucoup voir
parce que c'est toujours compliqué de
mobiliser derrière un président de la
République là on a vraiment le candidat
qui se qui se vient se poser en majesté
au milieu de ces troupes de ces troupes
et de ses militants avec avec l'idée
d'écraser un peu tout ce que d'écraser
ou au moins de rattraper de se mettre au
niveau de tout ce qu'on a pu voir comme
meeting depuis le début de la campagne
et de la pré campagne il y a eu beaucoup
de meeting réussi de la part d'Éric
Zemmour Marine Le Pen elle a joué sur
des meetings un peu plus petit plus
resserré là vraiment c'est c'est une
démonstration de force qui veut qui veut
faire aujourd'hui très bien merci
beaucoup François-Xavier avec nous en ce
début d'après-midi le discours de de
Macron est prévu à 16h mais on imagine
qu'il va être un peu en retard les
on peut pas on peut dire que les grandes
la grande activité du Midi n'a pas
vraiment encore commencé donc ça va
venir merci beaucoup merci beaucoup pour
une Amboise n'hésitez pas à nous
reprendre on va se balader un peu dans
les travers et essayer de vous trouver
quelques milliers de temps et voilà
merci merci beaucoup Vincent et merci à
François-Xavier vous nous faites signe
Vincent roseron et Riad Becker dès que
dès que vous avez du nouveau dès que
vous avez quelque chose à nous montrer
et à nous faire vivre en direct alors je
suis de retour en plateau avec Frédéric
Michaud donc pour pour recontactualiser
un petit peu donc on est à 8 jours on va
dire du premier tour il reste plus que 8
jours et c'est donc un rendez-vous à ne
pas manquer pour Emmanuel Macron qui qui
est rentré il faut dire très très tard
en campagne est-ce que c'est donc du
coup il fera un seul meeting avant le
premier tour est-ce que c'est pas un peu
risqué alors c'est très risqué et c'est
surtout sans précédent on a déjà eu des
présidents de la République sortant
[Musique]
en 2017 alors aujourd'hui c'est ce que
nous disent les intentions de vote notre
dernière intention de vote que nous
avons réalisé pour les échos et Radio
Classique en partenariat avec et
appartenance nous montre que
Emmanuel Macron est en tête qu'il
dispose d'un score de 28% 28% c'est 4
points de plus que le score qu'il avait
fait en
2017 et il est plutôt en stabilité cette
semaine il devance de 8 points donc
c'est quand même un écart important
Marine Le Pen qui est la deuxième
candidate donc il serait qualifiée avec
un score de 20% et puis en troisième
position Jean-Luc Mélenchon à 15% qui
lui pour l'instant n'est pas en mesure
ne serait pas en mesure d'accéder au
second tour selon les indications des
intentions de vote et puis encore
derrière Éric Zemmour a 10% donc deux
fois moins que Marine Le Pen et Valérie
Pécresse à 9% donc le premier enjeu pour
le chef de l'État c'est celui là c'est
consolider ce score et faire en sorte
que les intentions de vote se
transforment bien le jour J
à ce niveau là et et d'être en tête avec
un écart aussi important pour y penser
que c'est une situation confortable en
réalité ça ne l'est pas on a vu pendant
je vous coupe juste est-ce que c'est ça
d'en parler
François-Xavier Bourmaud est-ce que
est-ce que c'est ça le terme pédalé dans
la choucroute alors le fait d'être en
avance mais en même temps de pas non
plus briller par sa campagne je dirais
qu'il a une campagne qui a été
réalisée par intermittence évidemment
sous la pression sous la contrainte des
événements qui est quand même une
situation internationale très aiguë qui
capte son son attention et donc qui
mobilise son temps
et d'ailleurs les Français sont plutôt
satisfaits de la façon dont ils gèrent
la crise la crise en Ukraine mais aussi
par volonté
on voit bien que dans la stratégie de
campagne du chef de l'État
et d'ailleurs de tous les chefs de
l'État sortants il y a une volonté de
rester un petit peu en surplomb et de
conserver la rente institutionnelle la
prééminence que lui confère ça position
de président de la République c'est un
candidat mais c'est pas un candidat
comme les autres puisque précisément il
est sortant et donc voilà ça ça l'a
incité à avoir une campagne d'être plus
tardive qu'une entrée en campagne plus
tardive que que les autres et une
campagne un peu à distance alors après
il y a eu des événements de campagne
qui ont plus ou moins bien fonctionné
l'annonce de candidatures on peut dire
qu'elle était sobre avec cette lettre
c'est sans doute le bon format le
contenu était assez pauvre dans cette
dans cette lettre d'opinion cette
déclaration de candidature
ça n'a pas eu beaucoup d'impact mais
c'est le moment où sa gestion de la
guerre en Ukraine lui a permis de faire
un bon dans les intentions de vote et de
passer de 24 25 à 30 31%
. alors depuis quelques jours il a perdu
un petit peu de cette dynamique il a
perdu deux à trois points mais il en
conserve la majeure partie je dirais
qu'il en conserve plus de la moitié et
c'est vraiment ça son enjeu c'est de
conserver
cette dynamique jusqu'au premier tour
merci Frédéric on reviendra sur sur vous
dans quelques instants on va d'abord
aller voir Vincent roseron qui a qui est
à la rencontre d'une militante
d'Emmanuel Macron je vous laisse la
parole Vincent rose
oui effectivement je suis avec une
militante d'Emmanuel Macron là alors que
ça ça vient de commencer mais on va on
va essayer quand même de parler à cette
limite bonjour vous disiez que vous avez
est-ce que vous vous souvenez Emmanuel
Macron vous allez voter déjà pour lui il
y a 5 ans tout à fait tout à fait parce
que j'avais senti que c'était quelqu'un
d'exceptionnel et je trouve qu'il l'a
montré de par son âge et de par ce à
quoi il a été confronté et aujourd'hui
c'était important pour vous de revenir
ici pour quelle raison pour quelle
raison parce que je pense qu'il a pas pu
faire de campagne que c'est dommageable
ça risque de l'impôt lui qu'il est très
occupé par l'Ukraine qu'il a une
position vraiment très difficile et que
Marine Le Pen fait une campagne très
dangereuse oui alors l'idée c'est que
c'est pas c'est pas gagné pour Emmanuel
Macron selon vous non parce que je pense
qu'elle a accès sur un côté très
poujadiste des Français que ça peut
marcher et que les gens oublient qu'elle
est d'extrême droite et elle s'est
enrobée dans un côté
chatte douce qui est c'est pas la vérité
voilà ça ça fait très peur très bien
merci beaucoup en tout cas d'avoir été
avec nous voilà brune pour cette
interview de militante qui l'a dit se
méfie de Marine Le Pen aujourd'hui je
vais vous laisser suivre le début de ce
métier et je vous renvoie en plateau
merci on va laisser vivre les images du
coup la première animation on va dire de
de ce meeting qui qui est un petit peu
en retard
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
j'ai rien pour l'instant
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
alors donc on voit bien que c'est un DJ
qui a démarré qui a démarré donc le
meeting d'Emmanuel Macron
on voit pas encore grand monde dansé
enfin ça y est ça commence ça a l'air
d'être un peu festif je n'ai pas encore
le nom de ce DJ qui a démarré le meeting
d'Emmanuel Macron alors si vous vous le
connaissez n'hésitez pas à nous dire
dans le chat je vous suis sur Twitter
d'ailleurs vous êtes très très nombreux
dans le chat de Youtube je
j'ai du mal à lire tous vos commentaires
vous êtes plus de 2400 personnes à nous
regarder Vincent roseron sur place nous
dit que c'était worax worak laisse ce DJ
donc qui a qui a démarré le meeting à la
u Arena donc effectivement Frédéric
Michaud on en parlait donc il y a il y a
une question que François-Xavier
également un enjeu de mobilisation pour
ce pour ce midi est-ce que si la
démonstration est avérée est-ce que ça
rajoutera une dynamique une pièce dans
la machine oui en tout cas c'est la
c'est vraiment la fonction une des
fonctions d'un meeting c'est de c'est de
créer un effet de nombre alors il y a
des chiffres qui ont été avancés
on verra s'il y a un comptage ou pas ça
c'est important parce que c'est aussi
comme ça qu'on juge
la réussite d'un meeting est-ce que le
candidat a été capable de susciter
beaucoup d'affluences ou pas ensuite il
y a un effet de de masse
il faut montrer une foule homogène une
foule qui vibre à l'unisson et puis il
faut montrer aussi une foule
enthousiaste joyeuse là tout ce qu'on
tous convient de voir tous ces tous ces
événements qui qui sont en préambule de
la prise de parole du candidat ça vise à
faire des images et ça vise justement à
créer ce sentiment très positifs
d'énergie que doit dégager le
et en réalité les les personnes qui
constituent le public du meeting à
travers leur énergie et bien ça ça doit
se transmettre à l'ensemble du corps
électoral c'est ça la fonction d'un
meeting quand il est réussi alors là
justement on voit en direct donc les
images qui sont en ce moment diffusées
dans la dans la u Arena on vous dirait
que ce sont des paroles de militants en
tout cas peut-être de potentiel
électeurs de Macron puisque je vous le
rappelle il n'y a aucune prise de parole
qui est prévue avant le discours du chef
de l'État on va retrouver tout de suite
sur place Vincent roseron filmé par Riad
Bekir qui est de nouveau avec un
militant d'en marche
oui bonjour
chèque Alan Alan qui est venu pour ce
meeting Alan pour vous c'était important
de venir à ce meeting d'Emmanuel Macron
oui on s'est levait tôt ce matin on
vient de Normandie ah oui ça fait
des lois et du coup pourquoi est-ce que
c'était pourquoi c'était important vous
il fallait montrer que vous étiez
mobilisé oui ça ça m'a permis aussi
venir avec ma famille je pense que c'est
important pour de leur montrer qu'on est
qu'on agit aussi pour la France le vous
craignez un second tour face à Marine Le
Pen vous craignez les candidats pour
vous les militants doivent se mobiliser
pour montrer qu'ils sont là non je pense
qu'il y a pas il y a pas à craindre
ils sont tous en train de jouer sur nos
peurs à là où Macron parle plutôt
d'avenir et je pense que c'est plus
important l'avenir que le passé
qu'est-ce que vous attendez de ce
meeting aujourd'hui
à savoir ce qu'il veut ce qui veut nous
proposer exactement en fait tout
simplement parce qu'aujourd'hui en fait
c'est resté assez évasif je pense qu'il
a pas forcément eu le temps de nous en
parler tout ce qui est arrivé d'un
moment en Ukraine très bien merci
beaucoup Alan bon meeting
j'ai juste une petite question on a vu
juste derrière ce mi-temps vous
interviewez qu'il y a quelques sièges
vides et il y a beaucoup de gens dans le
chat qui nous demandent de filmer les
sièges pour voir si la salle est bien
remplie quelle est votre sentiment
est-ce qu'elle est remplie
alors cette salle est quand même assez
remplie il y a toujours des sièges
villes à certains endroits comme vous
avez pu le voir derrière moi j'ai
demandé à Riad justement de filmer un
peu les sièges qui sont à ce niveau là
qui ne sont pas alors la salle n'est pas
pleine pleine mais elle est quand même
assez remplie on peut le dire en fait
surtout ce qui est montré je pense sur
les images c'est surtout les plus
comment dire c'est les militants qui
sont de ce côté là avec les drapeaux qui
font des clapping en fait depuis le
début du meeting qui sont voilà les
militants les plus chauds pour Macron
qui sont chargés de mettre l'ambiance
mais effectivement beaucoup de personnes
qui sont présentes une ur Arena qui est
assez remplie mais effectivement il y a
encore des sièges libres on peut pas
dire que ça se joue à qui j'ai fermé
pour l'instant
merci Vincent Rozon on vous retrouve
tout à l'heure je rappelle pour ceux qui
nous regardent et qui met beaucoup de
personnes évidemment posent cette
question dans les tchats que la salle
était prévue pour 30
000 places assises la République en
marche à communiquer sur un nombre de
35000 participants inscrits on verra
donc à la fin évidemment tout ça c'est
encore une fois comme je me disais une
logique de communication mais ce n'est
pas parce que la salle est remplie que
ces gens se mobiliseront ou pas il y a
quand même toujours cette inconnue de
l'abstention Frédéric Michaud oui il y a
une il y a une inconnue de l'abstention
alors notre dernière indice de
participation s'élève à 66%
à une semaine du premier tour donc c'est
quand même très très bas alors
évidemment nous on pense que la semaine
prochaine notamment ce meeting les les
meetings des autres candidats puis les
émissions politiques et la campagne vont
faire leur effet la semaine prochaine
donc on devrait avoir une petite
remontée de de la participation mais il
est pas humble que un cas record
d'abstention soit battue peut-être que
la barre des 30% d'abstention sera
franchie si c'était le cas ce serait
évidemment quelque chose enfin avec des
conséquences démocratiques très très
graves l'élection présidentielle c'est
l'architecture même c'est la clé de vood
de des institutions de la 5ème
République et jusqu'à présent elle a été
assez épargnée parce qu'on appelle le
cycle l'abstentionniste vous souvenez
vous élections municipales si on
départementale régional on a battu des
records d'abstention c'est pas le cas
pour l'élection présidentielle on verra
si elle reste encore épargnée ou si au
contraire elle est atteinte par
cette abstention et
cette campagne très particulière d'abord
en période de pandémie ensuite avec les
effets de la guerre en Ukraine pour le
détourner l'attention et qu'on suspendu
la campagne pendant un certain temps
ça ce sont des éléments qui évidemment
n'ont pas aidé à la mobilisation
électorale à qui elle pourrait profiter
cette candidat Macron
c'est difficile de le c'est difficile de
le dire d'abord c'est un c'est
l'abstention c'est un phénomène qui
renvoie des causes très diverses et qui
peuvent s'agencer dans des combinaisons
multiples et variées mais ce qu'on sait
c'est que l'électorat d'Emmanuel Macron
sociologiquement les plus diplômés
davantage de catégorie sociaux
professionnels dites supérieur et donc
ce sont plutôt des des électeurs qui
font preuve de civisme et qui se
déplacent le jour J à l'inverse les
électeurs de les électorats de Jean-Luc
Mélenchon et de Marine Le Pen regroupe
davantage de catégories populaires
ouvriers des employés et donc cela se
mobilise moins c'était d'ailleurs ce que
nous avions vu lors des élections
régionales ce qui avait
eu pour conséquence des scores très
décevants pour pour le Front national
pour le rassemblement national
voilà ça c'est un enjeu pour pour Marine
Le Pen mais pour Emmanuel Macron il peut
y avoir de la démobilisation par
certitude de la victoire l'idée que les
jeux sont faits l'idée qu'Emmanuel
Macron est en tête avec un écart
important sur Marine Le Pen tout ça ça
peut démobiliser une partie de son
électorat sans même parler du calendrier
électoral on sera en entrera dans dans
les vacances scolaires est-ce que tous
les tous les électeurs vont bien penser
à faire une procuration avant de partir
en vacances voilà ça ça fait partie des
éléments d'incertitude qui peuvent
alimenter l'abstention alors si je
reviens sur la première militante que
l'équipe de l'envoyer sur spéciaux sur
place à filmer elle est elle a parlé de
d'une
des premières raisons pour pour
lesquelles elle allait voter Macron lors
de cette campagne c'était qu'elle avait
qu'elle pensait qu'elle estimait qu'il
avait une stature présidentielle et
qu'il avait c'était quelqu'un
d'exceptionnel et qu'il avait je cite
très bien gérer la guerre en Ukraine
est-ce qu'on a un moyen de comptabiliser
le les intentions de vote si jamais
cette guerre n'avait jamais eu lieu pour
Macron alors on sait ce qui était ces
intentions de vote avant
l'invasion de l'Ukraine par la par la
Russie et les intentions de votre
d'Emmanuel Macron étaient extrêmement
stables on voit bien qu'il a réussi
quand même à conserver une grande partie
de son socle électoral de 2017 ces
électeurs de 2017 lui sont quasiment à
deux tiers restés fidèles il y a une
autre candidate qui est dans le même cas
de figure c'est Marine Le Pen tous les
autres candidats
plus de difficultés à
retrouver leur électorat naturel c'est
le cas évidemment pour pour Valérie
Pécresse mais c'est le cas aussi pour
pour Jean-Luc Mélenchon et donc voilà
jusqu'à la guerre en Ukraine mais il
n'était même pas encore candidat jusqu'à
la guerre en Ukraine ces intentions de
vote était autour de 24 25 %
on peut faire l'hypothèse que c'était
plutôt pour lui à ce moment-là des
intentions de vote plancher et que avec
une campagne un peu différente peut-être
moins moins marquée par par la crise en
Ukraine avec aussi peut-être davantage
de présence du candidat sur sur le
terrain peut-être plus de meeting pas
seulement un seul peut-être que les
intentions de vote auraient
aurait pu
se développer un petit peu mais là on
est vraiment dans dans une vraie
spéculation puisque il y a eu cette
guerre en Ukraine qui a eu un effet très
positif pour les intentions de vote
alors vous voyez toujours les images qui
sont derrière qui défilent très vite
d'ailleurs qui font un petit peu mal aux
yeux ben c'est ce qui est en ce moment
montré sur les écrans de la grande salle
qui s'appelait à l'époque u Arena qui
s'appelle maintenant Paris défense Paris
La Défense Arena voilà donc ce sont
j'imagine des photos de français de
militants peut-être de soutien ou de
potentiel électeurs d'Emmanuel Macron
puisque je le rappelle donc
ce meeting dans ce meeting le seul
meeting du président candidat avant le
premier tour il n'y a que Emmanuel
Macron qui parlera et il est censé
parler à partir de 16h donc maintenant
dans moins de 10 petites minutes juste
avant il y avait donc un DJ 7 pour pour
chauffer un petit peu la salle et puis
donc ces images qui sont projetées
au-dessus de cette salle qui se veut un
petit peu comme une salle de sport on va
dire octogonale au centre comme vous
voyez sur les images au centre de la
salle un peu comme un ring de boxe donc
j'imagine que
Macron
se promènera on va dire sur cette scène
au beau milieu de la foule donc tous les
gradins sont sont autour il y a
également des des panneaux enfin ça
ressemble vraiment à un meeting
spectacle a tendance sportif on va dire
voilà il a voulu reprendre un petit peu
les codes de grands événements sportifs
en tout cas j'ai beaucoup de monde dans
le dans le chat qui
qui me parle de l'affaire making c'est
évidemment on peut pas faire l'économie
de cette question aujourd'hui Frédéric
Michaud Guillaume tabard d'ailleurs
éditorialiste politique au Figaro
écrivait hier que l'ombre d'un doute
planait désormais sur la campagne
d'Emmanuel Macron en parlant évidemment
de cette affaire McKinsey en quoi cette
affaire fragilise Macron est-ce qu'elle
a fragilisé Macron dans les intentions
de vote parce qu'il y a eu un effet déjà
et est-ce que
ça peut jouer sur le résultat du premier
tour alors pour l'instant cette affaire
qui se développe vraiment depuis le
milieu de la de cette semaine n'a pas eu
d'effet dans les intentions de vote
les intentions de vote du président de
la République cette semaine sont restés
particulièrement stable mais c'est
peut-être quelque chose qui est en train
d'infuser dans l'opinion publique donc
on va surveiller ça de très très près la
dernière semaine on sait que les deux
dernières semaines c'est le moment où le
plus grand nombre de citoyens
s'intéresse à l'élection plus on
approche du scrutin plus l'attention des
électeurs est forte et donc là il y a
évidemment un
élément dans l'actualité cette polémique
cette affaire autour des cabinets de
consultants qui est qui est
potentiellement un danger pour pour le
chef de l'État et l'une des fonctions du
meeting d'aujourd'hui c'est précisément
de créer une diversion on a vu la
semaine dernière dimanche dernier dans
une émission le chef de l'État s'énerver
un petit peu
et essayer de mettre un terme à cette
affaire qui s'est prolongé toute la
semaine
il faudra voir les développements de
cette semaine ça pourrait se traduire
par un petit tassement des des
intentions de vote en faveur d'Emmanuel
Macron et peut-être même davantage si
des révélations étaient faites
alors nous sommes toujours en direct
pour suivre et commenter le premier et
le seul meeting de campagne d'Emmanuel
Macron ce qui se déroule en ce moment à
la défense enfin juste à côté de la
défense à Nanterre je vois que Vincent
roseron notre équipe sur place avec Ryad
Becker et à côté d'un nouveau militant
je vais lui laisser la parole tout de
suite
oui effectivement brune je suis avec
Romain romain militant pour Emmanuel
Macron qui me disait qu'il y a 5 ans il
était déjà présent derrière Emmanuel
Macron et aujourd'hui vous mobilisez à
nouveau tout à fait ouais pour moi
c'était vraiment une évidence une
évidence d'être là aujourd'hui j'ai été
là il y a 5 ans pour la première
campagne j'ai suivi Emmanuel Macron
pendant ces 5 dernières années je pense
que son bilan est très solide il a
réussi à traverser les crises à mettre
en place des réforme vraiment
importantes pour la France et donc pour
moi c'est une évidence de signer pour 50
plus et le but aujourd'hui c'est
d'arriver à montrer qu'il y a du monde
face à Marine Le Pen c'est ça exactement
il reste 10 jours pour faire campagne 10
jours projets contre projet pour montrer
que le projet d'Emmanuel Macron est bien
meilleur que celui de l'extrême droite
et donc pareil comme je disais c'est une
évidence d'être ici de défendre le
projet de faire du bruit et de montrer
qu'on est vraiment derrière le candidat
pour ces derniers jours est-ce que vous
êtes confiant pour ce pour ce premier
tour moi je suis très confiant encore
une fois je pense que le bilan parle de
lui-même il y a une belle dynamique là
qui s'enclenche depuis quelques semaines
depuis Emmanuel Macron est rentré en
campagne donc je suis très confiant
qu'on pourra l'emporter lors du premier
tour et que il passera pour un deuxième
mandat très bien merci beaucoup Robin
merci voilà brune pour ce mi-temps qui
était présent à la défense Arena je vous
laisse le la parole merci Vincent merci
Vincent Rozon à toute à tout à l'heure
on va revenir du coup de sur cette sur
cette salle donc je le disais juste
avant donc une salle qui qui contient
35000 places 30000 places à 6 il me
semble et puis c'est une scénographie un
peu particulière pour un pour un meeting
qu'est-ce que vous en avez à dire
justement vous avez raison c'est c'est
vraiment particulier alors d'avoir une
scène centrale et un candidat entouré de
de toutes parts il y a tout de même des
précédents il y a des précédents dans
des campagnes de de par exemple dans la
campagne de 2006 2007 Ségolène Royal
faisait souvent ça mais peut-être dans
des salles de plus petits de plus petits
format justement pour insister sur le
côté participatif là ce que veut mettre
en valeur le candidat c'est le fait
d'être au centre de la foule de montrer
qu'il y a une proximité de jouer aussi
sur le rappel du grand débat national et
des différentes réunions qui se
déroulaient selon le même format
il me semble que Macron est en train
d'arriver dans la salle on me signale
dans l'oreillette
mais on peut continuer à commenter ces
images mais j'ai vu en tout cas Brigitte
Macron arrivé peut-être accompagné du
président
et en tout cas cette scène ça peut être
aussi à double tranchant parce que ça ça
va donner le sentiment d'un homme seul
et ça c'est l'une des faiblesses
d'Emmanuel Macron quand on regarde les
études qualitatives les personnes que
nous interrogeons nous disent que ils
décident seul il est il est seul il est
faiblement entouré d'ailleurs il y a pas
eu vraiment de personnalité forte qui
ont émergé dans le cadre de ce
quinquennat peut-être hormis Édouard
Philippe
qu'on a vu dans le public juste à
l'instant mais et donc cette
scénographie elle renforce le le fait
que le macronisme c'est d'abord et avant
tout Emmanuel Macron et et pas l'idée
d'une équipe c'était un peu ce sur quoi
essayer de jouer Valérie Pécresse au
moment de sa désignation de montrer
qu'elle elle avait une équipe qui était
entouré par des personnalités
compétentes c'est pas le c'est pas l'axe
qui a pris Emmanuel Macron et et cette
scénographie renforce cet élément là
alors j'ai bien l'impression que cette
fois-ci le président va être à l'heure
car il est 15h59 précisément et qui a un
tout dernier clip on va dire qui retrace
la présidence Emmanuel Macron qui est
diffusé alors que sur les images que
filme nos envoyés spéciaux Riad Becky et
Vincent roseron le président se prépare
à arriver à entrer dans l'arène
si je puis me permettre l'expression est
totalement légitime puisqu'il rentre à
l'Arena et il va monter donc sur cette
scène si particulière
si symbolique que vient de décrire
Frédéric Michaud ça ça donne l'aspect
d'un président candidat un peu seul mais
aussi un petit peu
narcissique on va dire quand même
au milieu ça aussi
le meeting
l'élection présidentielle c'est un
exercice narcissique et le meeting est
là aussi pour façonner une identité
charismatique du candidat donc il faut
évidemment mettre en valeur le candidat
le montrer montrer ses compétences
montrer ses compétences techniques sa
connaissance des dossiers c'est
peut-être
la fonction de ce clip de campagne qui
qui retrace le bilan année par année du
quinquennat il faut montrer aussi des
qualités des qualités humaines des
qualités
relationnelles
des peut-être des qualités d'humour
aussi
et ça c'est vraiment le rôle du meeting
l'équipe de campagne d'Emmanuel Macron a
aussi annoncé qui aurait de
l'interaction et un meeting c'est
normalement c'est tout sauf interactif
puisque c'est une parole descendante
alors la foule réagit
le candidat il y a pas de question qui
viennent de la salle dans le cadre d'un
meeting on va voir comment
ils mettent en scène cette interaction
peut-être que le côté interactif c'était
justement toutes les vidéos qu'on avait
avant et que là le président va se
livrer un exercice seul on va dire qu'on
fasse au public un discours qui est
censé durer une heure d'après les
informations dont nous disposons
de la volonté et alors que dans le chat
YouTube vous êtes toujours aussi
nombreux vous êtes 3400 à nous suivre
merci et merci beaucoup et
idem sur Le Figaro.fr il y a de nombreux
de nombreux internautes fidèles à Figaro
Life qui sont qui sont au rendez-vous je
laisse à l'usu je les salué vol pose du
34 et Christian Léon Toussaint bien sûr
Charles Martel chardon bleu des
signatures très très connues de Figaro
life puisqu'ils sont très souvent avec
nous et comment très souvent l'actualité
avec nous je je les remercie d'ailleurs
pour ça
alors on va laisser du coup maintenant
les images de notre envoyé spécial
[Musique]
oui voilà donc derrière moi vous voyez
c'est trois drapeaux à la manière des
stades de foot qui va être mis en place
c'est notre projet 50 plus Manu 2022 le
tifo annoncé par Emmanuel Macron on sent
l'inspiration on sent l'inspiration du
du football Manu 2022 avec les couleurs
qui ressemblent quand même beaucoup à
celle de l'Olympique de Marseille donc
voilà cette tribune qui est derrière où
il y a le plus d'ambiance depuis le
début comme on l'a dit il y a plusieurs
tribunes et de celle-là où il y a le
plus d'ambiance et d'ailleurs le
présentateur le citron pas puisqu'il est
au milieu de cette tribune à essayer
d'arranguer la foule
quelque chose de formidable aujourd'hui
on va on va vous solliciter tout de
suite c'est ce qu'on va faire tout seul
j'ai vu
cette vidéo parmi vous ici même et je
sais que dans la meilleure chose à faire
c'est ce qu'on va faire on va faire on
va solliciter tout le monde on va couper
la musique on va couper la lumière on va
finalement se mettre quasiment d'endroit
pour ainsi dire dans le noir aujourd'hui
pour vivre un moment unique pour garder
des images qui seront vus à travers la
France et au-delà donc on va vraiment
mettre le minimum de lumière et
c'est ce qu'on va faire puisque j'ai vu
que certains avaient des tubes lumineux
parmi vous ici même et je sais que vous
en avez encore à faire c'est ce qu'on va
faire on va faire on va solliciter tout
le monde on va couper la musique on va
couper la lumière on va finalement se
mettre quasiment dans le noir pour ainsi
dire dans le noir aujourd'hui pour vivre
un moment unique pour garder des images
qui seront vues à travers la France et
au-delà donc on va vraiment mettre le
minimum de lumière et on va solliciter
tout Paris des défenses Arena je vais
vous demander d'allumer s'il vous plaît
vos téléphones les torches de vos
téléphones pour qu'on ait des images
uniques de ce qui se passe aujourd'hui
cet après-midi je voudrais qu'il pense
seul téléphone qui ne soit pas allumé
pas une seule torse pas un seul flash
qu'il ne soit pas avec un petit peu de
musique pour montrer qu'on est prêt à
immortaliser cette présence avec nous
tous les téléphones allumés cet
après-midi pour qu'on soit une pluie
d'étoiles à l'intérieur de Paris La
Défense Arena qui est pas une seule
personne qui ne se sent pas impliquée
dans ce moment unique
dans ce rassemblement ici alors oui les
réseaux sociaux bien sûr mais aussi ici
chacun côte à côte avec ce sentiment de
participer via aussi son téléphone cet
après-midi tout le monde
[Applaudissements]
allez je voudrais voir maintenant c'est
les bras qui bougent les bras qui
bougent mais l'admission au rythme de la
musique on est dans ce bon détail
incroyable et la sollicitation de toutes
et de tous passe par votre participation
ici de vos téléphones respectifs
[Musique]
allez horrible horrible de la musique
les téléphones s'il vous plaît partout
[Applaudissements]
qu'on soit pas spectateur
mais acteur de ce rassemblement
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
mesdames messieurs vous pouvez vraiment
vous applaudir applaudir votre voisin
votre voisine parce que ça aussi c'était
de concours qu'on a cet après-midi et je
voulais évoquer tout à l'heure dans la
similitude au max maintient
l'international on a fait la composition
presque de l'équipe on aura bien sûr
l'arrivée du candidat mais il y a aussi
un moment important si l'on est c'est
celui de la Marseillaise sur match
international et où que vous soyez je
vais vous demander de vous lever s'il
vous plaît qu'on se fasse quelque chose
qui va nous filer les poils et ce
sentiment qu'on va vivre quelque chose
d'unique et ça passe par votre
participation et toutes et tous alors où
que vous soyez à Paris la Défense Arena
je vais vous demander s'il vous plaît de
vous lever et on va vivre ensemble
horrible n'est jamais aussi de toutes et
tous cette Marseillaise à l'unisson
attention
on y va tous ensemble allons aux enfants
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
ah bon bravo à toutes et à tous c'est
imminent bien attendant encore une vidéo
pour vous regardez sur les écrans
[Applaudissements]
trésors de créativité des ressources
d'inépuisables
mais je ne pense pas simplement là à
tous nos talents je pense à chaque
Français à chaque fois soucieux de
bienfaits et de mener une vie digne de
lui elle est là la vraie richesse d'un
pays et le mandat qui nous est donné
c'est de créer de l'unité où il y avait
de la division
de redonner à ceux qui sont exclus la
simple dignité de l'existence leur juste
place dans le projet national
de permettre à ceux qui créent invente
innove entreprennent de réaliser leurs
projets
de rendre le pouvoir à ceux qui veulent
faire et font
le mandat du peuple ce n'est pas
d'instaurer le gouvernement d'une élite
pour elle-même
c'est de rendre au peuple cette dignité
collective qui ne s'accompagne d'aucune
exclusion
je refuse pour ma part de choisir entre
l'ambition et l'esprit de justice
je refuse ce dogme que pour bâtir
l'égalité il faudrait renoncer à
l'excellence pas plus que pour réussir
il ne faut renoncer à donner une place à
chacun le sel même de notre République
et de savoir conjuguer ces exigences oui
de faire tout cela
en quelque sorte en même temps
[Musique]
cette voix désoriente je l'entends bien
tous ceux qui s'étaient habitués à faire
carrière sur les schémas anciens
il en est ainsi à chaque période
alors nous resterons fidèle à cette
promesse de nos commencements cette
promesse que nous tiendrons
parce qu'elle est la plus grande
la plus belle qui soit
faire à l'homme enfin
un pays digne de lui
mesdames messieurs formidable vidéo
connaît découvert au Manon dans
l'oreillette que le candidat n'est plus
très loin il nous reste il nous reste
deux trois deux trois moments à vivre
ensemble avant son arrivée je voudrais
puisqu'on est encore dans cette
thématique dans ce parallèle avec le
sport qu'on fasse des moments aussi très
intéressant parce qu'il l'est aussi
participatif c'est du claping alors je
vais vous demander s'il vous plaît ou
que vous soyez à parler de force Arena
et croyez le bien ici comme partout
ailleurs on le fait c'est un moment
d'union et de communion d'avoir tout le
monde avec les bras au dessus de la tête
s'il vous plaît vraiment tendu qu'on est
ce sentiment ne serait-ce qu'avec les
images qu'on voit qu'on est tous
et toutes dans cette même logique tous
les bras en l'air bien évidemment si
votre voisin ne le fait pas vous le
mettez un coup de poineras après juste
participe à ce moment-là tout le monde
qui est pas une seule personne s'il vous
plaît
avec les bras qui ne sont pas au dessus
de la tête Ambroise et derrière moi et
là on va faire ce qui devrait finalement
pas arriver longtemps maintenant on va
se faire un silence de cathédrale avant
de démarrer ce clapping tout le monde
avec les bras au dessus de la tête
attention
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
alors Mesdames Messieurs puisqu'on est
plus caca que quelques minutes à peine
quelques secondes de l'arrivée du
candidat on fait on va faire ce qu'on
fait aussi dans les stades on va
solliciter les tribunes et on va faire
un challenge en contribué voir celle qui
finalement sera le poumon de cet
événement et de se rassemblement alors
on va voir ce que ça va donner ici
mesdames messieurs est-ce qu'on peut
tout petit peu baisser la musique s'il
vous plaît et on va voir ce que ça va
donner ici ou que vous soyez est-ce que
tu peux montrer tes filles s'il te plaît
la tribune j'ai cette tribune ici
alors mesdames messieurs pour vous quel
sur cette tribu là on va se faire une
roue là une roula qui sera de haut en
bas pour vous qui êtes tout à fait là
haut vous êtes prêts en démarre devant
et on va noter cette tribune avec le
haut là qui va bien vous êtes prêt
attention
ok j'ai compris que la tribune soit nous
entends pas Sois préfère rester comme
elle est en valeur refaire on vous
laisse une deuxième chance parce que
j'ai l'impression que ça pourrait râler
à côté attention toute la tribune qui
est avec moi on y va vous êtes prêt oh
pas mal là aussi on vous a pas entendu
on fait une dernière fois mais là il
faut vraiment qu'on vous entendre
parfaitement attention tout le monde
pour cette tribune
[Musique]
pas mal pas mal pas mal on va continuer
viens on va voir ce que ça va donner de
ce côté-là pour la force et ça sera
peut-être un tout petit peu plus
difficile
mais mais Monsieur le Premier Ministre
vous étiez lors de France - Angleterre
en tribune vous avez vu formidable vous
étiez rock n' roll sur la ola je peux
pas croire que ça sera pas le cas ici
alors vous commencez oui oui commencer
assis vous savez comment vous finissez
une attention vous connaissez le procès
donc là mesdames messieurs vous êtes
forcément la caméra vous pouvez pas
faire autrement qu'être extraordinaire
et puis où que vous soyez parce qu'on a
un grand angle attention pour toute
cette tribune là mesdames messieurs un
truc qui ne s'est jamais fait une ola
gouvernementale attention alors
attention
vous faites presque plus de bruit que on
leur fait une deuxième fois allez
attention
pas mal bravo bravo vous a été vous êtes
même applaudit c'est un truc de fou
alors il nous en reste deux il nous en
reste deux tribune il paraît qu'ici tout
à l'heure c'était incroyable sachantée
ça hurler on aurait écrit les Rolling
Stones mesdames messieurs alors pour
voir si vous êtes en pleine forme aussi
avant qu'on aille bien sûr du côté de
ceux qui n'ont rien lâcher tout à
l'heure alors attention vous êtes prêts
mesdames messieurs même ce monsieur là
en jaune attention ou que vous souhaitez
de ce côté là
pas mal une dernière
pas mal il nous reste une tribune le
poumon de Paris La Défense Arena
alors attention vous êtes prêts
[Applaudissements]
et encore une
et vous savez quoi on va se faire toute
la salle avec kaola qui n'est pas ici oh
allez allez allez on continue on
continue on continue on continue on
continue allez allez on continue mes la
mission vous arrête pas pour ce grand
moment qui va bien sûr c'était
incroyable on reprend là où là où là et
je voudrais toute la salle cette fois-ci
on ne s'arrête pas on va vers ma droite
mesdames messieurs ou que vous soyez
tout là-haut aussi attention
allez allez
allez on continue on continue mesdames
Messieurs les gouvernements ici tout le
monde et on fait un deuxième tour allez
tu es formidable formidable public alors
je vous propose comme aussi dans un
match international convives ce
mouvement formidable qui est le compte à
rebours et je voudrais qu'on les graines
ensemble on va démarrer à 15 jusqu'à 0
et je dois absolument que toutes et tous
on soit prêt le livre de 15 à 0 alors
attention
vous êtes prêts
mais la messieurs attention tout
l'ensemble c'est parti regardez les
écrans 15 14
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
merci
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
merci d'être là
est-ce que vous entendez la ferveur
[Applaudissements]
merci merci d'être venu des quatre coins
du pays de toutes les régions
et je sais pour certains même de nos
outre-mer
[Applaudissements]
c'est sûr
heureux d'être parmi vous aujourd'hui
[Applaudissements]
étant dit qu'il y a quelques heures de
Paris on bombarde la démocratie
tandis non
on va tout de suite se redonner une
règle que vous connaissez
la guerre en Ukraine
[Applaudissements]
nous faisons tous chaque jour pour
pouvoir l’arrêter évidemment nous la
condamnons mais ici comme nous quand
nous sommes tous ensemble nous ne
ciflons pas personne jamais jamais
jamais
parce que la démocratie ce sont des
combats historiques parfois comme ce que
nous menons
mais toujours avec le respect et
l'exigence
certains aujourd'hui je le disais
bombarde
à quelques heures de Paris d'autres
voudraient nous ramener en France des
années en arrière et vous êtes là tous
militants de l'idéal
nous sommes là
dans la plus grande salle d'Europe pour
dire que nul ne nous fera reculer nous
sommes là
dans ce moment marqué par la guerre
la gravité
pour rappeler que la France a toujours
quelque chose à dire au monde
nous sommes là pour affirmer que nous
Français
n'en avons fini ni avec l'humanisme ni
avec les lumières
nous sommes là mes amis
à huit jours du premier tour de cette
élection présidentielle pour convaincre
pour mobiliser nous sommes là pour faire
advenir un projet de progrès
[Applaudissements]
d'avenir
pour notre France et pour notre Europe
alors
vous vous en souvenez
[Applaudissements]
en 2017 nous portions un projet
d'émancipation de lutte contre
lastination à résidence
de progrès
comme disait certains c'était même notre
projet
les amis
malgré les crises
nous n'avons jamais renoncé malgré les
crises nous avons tenu nos promesses
pour mettre fin à ce mal français qui
était le chômage de masse il fallait
s'attaquer aux vieux tabou sur la
fiscalité le droit du travail et
l'assurance chômage nous l'avons fait
et le taux de chômage est au plus bas
depuis 15 ans
pour en finir avec la
désindustrialisation il fallait lever
les freins à l'entrepreneuriat à
l'innovation à l'investissement nous
l'avons fait
et pour la première fois depuis 30 ans
s'ouvre davantage d'usines qui ne
s'enferment
pour que le travail fait mieux
pour que le travail puis mieux
et permettent à chacun de vivre
dignement il fallait baisser les
cotisations l'impôt sur le revenu
supprimer la taxe d'habitation nous
l'avons fait
et le pouvoir d'achat a augmenté de
manière historique notamment pour les
travailleurs les plus modestes
pour relever le défi du climat il
fallait accompagner les français pour
rénover l'horlogements changer leur
voiture on l'a fait
et les émissions de gaz à effet de serre
ont baissé deux fois plus vite qu'avant
pour offrir les mêmes chances
à nos enfants il fallait prendre des
décisions radicales passer le congé
paternité de 14 à 28 jours
la scolarité obligatoire de 6 à 3 ans
réduire les effectifs
des classes en cpc1 dans les quartiers
les plus pauvres nous l'avons fait
pour permettre à notre jeunesse de
trouver sa voie il fallait développer
l'apprentissage jusqu'à doubler le
nombre d'apprentis nous l'avons fait
pour protéger les Français du terrorisme
il fallait continuer de changer nos lois
renforcer nos services de renseignement
nous l'avons fait
et je n'oublie à ce moment aucune des
victimes de tous nos attentats
nos blessés
les familles de toutes ces victimes nous
sommes à leur côté
pour garantir la sécurité pour tous
il fallait investir dans notre police
dans notre justice recruter 10 000
policiers gendarmes supplémentaires
augmenter de 30%, le budget de notre
justice bâtir une justice de proximité
plus forte nous l'avons fait
pour répondre à la crise des gilets
jaunes à la demande de proximité il
fallait organiser le retour de l'état
des services publics dans nos
territoires avec une maison française
par canton le transfert dans nos villes
de province de plusieurs services et de
milliers de fonctionnaires nous l'avons
fait
pour faire face à la crise sanitaire il
fallait protéger tout à la fois la santé
les emplois l'éducation de nos enfants
nos étudiants
avec l'investissement dans nos hôpitaux
et la mobilisation extraordinaire de nos
soignants avec
applaudissez
avec le quoi qu'il en coûte pour les
travailleurs les indépendants les
artisans et pour ne laisser personne au
bord du chemin avec l'école ouverte pour
nos enfants
avec le repas à 1 euro pour nos
étudiants nous l'avons fait
et tant d'autres tant d'autres
quotidiens ainsi améliorer
ce jeune garçon en situation de handicap
qui ne pouvait aller à l'école et qui
grâce au recrutement à la titularisation
de milliers d'accompagnants suit
désormais la classe avec les autres
ils sont 100 000 de plus par rapport à
2017 à pouvoir ainsi aller comme lui à
l'école au collège au lycée cette jeune
adolescente qui grâce au passes cultures
a trouvé le chemin d'une librairie
ils sont plus d'un million plus d'un
million
à avoir quand même découvert une œuvre
un art une vocation parfois
cette maman seule qui était à découvert
le 10 du mois et qui grâce au service
public des pensions alimentaires vit
désormais plus sereinement
ce couple de femmes qui grâce à la
procréation médicalement assistée a pu
avoir l'enfant dont elle parlait depuis
des années
[Applaudissements]
et cette femme battue par son mari qui
s'était enfermé dans le silence et qui
grâce au point d'accueil mis en place
dans les commissariats à la formation de
nos policiers de nos gendarmes a enfin
trouvé la force de parler de déposer
plainte d'être défendu
oui mes amis
tout cela
étant de choses c'était notre projet et
c'est maintenant notre bilan nous
l'avons fait
alors je sais bien
je sais bien ce qu'on nous dit
je sais bien qu'on nous dit qu'on ne
gagne pas sur un bilan mais c'est le
vôtre celui de votre travail de votre
engagement malgré les crises nous nous
sommes jamais arrêtés soyez-en fiers
pourtant
[Applaudissements]
pourtant comme vous
je vois encore tant de vie empêcher
comme vous
je sais toutes les lenteurs qui
alimentent l'impatience tant de blocage
qui nourrissent la colère et moi aussi
vous savez comme vous je me suis parfois
impatienté ça allait trop lentement et
ça n'allait pas assez loin
mes amis
comme vous
je sais toutes ces vies
encore empêcher
comme vous
je vois
les difficultés à finir le moi les
situations d'insécurité
les difficultés qui se multiplient
parfois étant de progrès à accomplir
pour faire reculer l'extrémisme c'est
pourquoi c'est pourquoi mes amis
c'est pourquoi
notre projet pour 2022 sera à nouveau un
projet de droit réel un projet de
solidarité
un projet de progrès social
oui comme vous comme vous mes amis je ne
me résoudrai jamais à ce que des
Français qui travaillent vois tout leur
salaire partir en plein d'essence en
facture en loyer et renonce finalement à
offrir un cadeau à leur enfant c'est un
juste
alors dès cet été
alors
d'abord nous n'avons pas attendu
face à ce défi du pouvoir d'achat le
gouvernement s'est déjà mobilisé depuis
des mois c'est l'équivalent de plus de
20 milliards d'euros par an pour
protéger les ménages face aux
délectricité de gaz et les bloquer c'est
aussi ce qui a permis de résister face à
toutes les augmentations dont celle de
l'essence c'est depuis hier la ristourne
décidé mais il nous faut
[Musique]
il nous faut aller plus loin
le vrai pouvoir d'achat c'est celui qui
vient du travail qui est durable par
lequel quand on travaille on gagne plus
c'est pourquoi dès cet été je veux
permettre au travailleur de pouvoir
toucher une prime de pouvoir d'achat
allant jusqu'à 6000 euros sans charge ni
impôt
dès cet été
les travailleurs indépendants gagneront
davantage
550 euros de plus chaque année au niveau
du SMIC
[Musique]
et parce qu'à nouveau c'est 5 années de
plus doivent être les 5 années du
travail du Mérite de la liberté nous
devons continuer d'avancer et nous
créerons le compte épargne-temps
universel
ce compte
suivra chaque salarié tout au long de sa
vie il sera mobilisable dans les moments
clés de la vie soit pour souffler
avoir du temps soit pour accélérer ses
projets et avoir de l'argent
oui je ne me résoudrai jamais
jamais à ce qu'après une vie de travail
des retraités puissent encore manquer
d'argent et de voir aller à l'aide
alimentaire c'est un juste
nous avons pu durant ces cinq années
améliorer plusieurs minima sociaux et
améliorer certaines retraites
pour nos paysans pour nos artisans
mais dans les prochains mois ensemble je
veux que nous portions à 1100 euros la
pension minimale de retraite pour une
carrière complète c'est justice
et nous prendrons en compte les
carrières longues l'invalidité les
métiers les plus pénibles je ne me
résoudrai jamais à ce que des mères
renoncent à leur carrière parce qu'elles
veulent fonder une famille c'est un
juste
c'est pourquoi nous créerons un droit
opposable à la garde d'enfants nous
accompagnerons nos mères qui sont un
travail exceptionnel comme sur beaucoup
d'autres en la matière
et nous revaloriserons
de 50% l'aide versée aux mamans seules
[Musique]
je ne me résoudrai jamais
à laisser des familles dans l'angoisse
rester sans solution face au grand âge
c'est un juste nous le savons l'un des
défis des années qui viennent et ce
vieillissement c'est une chance
mais un défi
nous prendrons en charge les travaux
pour adapter les logements des personnes
les plus âgées nous proposerons deux
heures d'aide à domicile en plus par
semaine pour tous
pour que tout ceux qui le peuvent
puissent rester chez eux
permettre
à tous nos compatriotes qui font ces
métiers si difficiles si essentiel du
soin de l'accompagnement de nos aînés de
le faire mieux d'être mieux rémunéré et
permettre
à tous nos aînés qui le peuvent de
vieillir chez eux avec leurs proches
et quand il ne peuvent plus alors de les
accompagner
dans des établissements dignes et pour
cela nous recruterons 50000 infirmiers
et aide-soignants et nous renforcerons
les contrôles
cartouche tous nous avons été indignés
par les révélations faites sur certains
établissements
cela ne vaut pas pour tous et beaucoup
font un travail admirable mais cela ne
doit plus exister jamais
nos vies leur vie valent plus que tous
les profils
je ne me résoudrai jamais
[Applaudissements]
à ce qu'on puisse
faire des économies faire des économies
au détriment des Français les plus
précaires les plus modestes tandis que
d'autres fraudes c'est un juste on a
tout entendu sur nos aides sociales tout
mais nous avons appris ensemble durant
ces cinq années nous avons mis en place
le fameux prélèvement à la source
il a permis
d'être plus juste et de lutter contre la
faute et bien maintenant ce que je veux
faire pour les 5 années qui viennent
c'est la solidarité à la source celle
qui permettra
de manière
plus simple
plus efficace
de verser ses aides à toutes celles et
ceux qui en ont besoin et de lutter
contre tous les fraudeurs
je ne me résoudrai jamais à ce que face
aux crises
notre jeunesse sombre dans la solitude
le désespoir parfois c'est un juste
c'est pourquoi
c'est pourquoi la santé mentale
sera une priorité nationale
je ne me résoudrai jamais non plus à ce
que nos étudiants abandonnent parce
qu'on parce qu'ils sont livrés à
eux-mêmes dans le maquis des premières
années de l'université c'est un juste
c'est pourquoi nous donnerons la
priorité à l'orientation
les places dans les filières seront
fixées en fonction des besoins de la
nation l'autonomie des universités
franchira une nouvelle étape
je ne me résoudrai jamais avoir des
quartiers entiers de notre République
être stigmatisé n'avoir parfois pas les
mêmes chances c'est un juste
à Marseille nous avons lancé
nous avons lancé une dynamique inédite
ce que j'appellerais un laboratoire de
volonté
Marseille en grand
et depuis la rénovation urbaine jusqu'à
l'école en passant par le sport la
culture le soutien à l'économie va
révolutionner la politique de la ville
alors oui nous nous appuyons sur cette
expérience mais aussi sur ce que nous
avons fait en doublant le budget de la
rénovation urbaine en ouvrant 300 cités
éducatives en formant à l'emploi nous
irons plus loin
je ne résoudrai
pas davantage
[Applaudissements]
à ce que nos campagnes elles aussi
soient envoyées à l'isolement parfois au
préjugés ou n'est pas les mêmes chances
nous aimons nos ruralités nous avons
tant fait avec leurs habitants
alors oui
nous finirons de couvrir tout le
territoire entrée au débit en réseau
mobile comme nous poursuivrons la
réouverture des petites lignes
ferroviaires
je ne me résoudrai jamais
est-ce que certains de nos compatriotes
puissent vivre dans l'insécurité
la présence des forces de l'ordre sur la
voie publique sera doublée 200 brigades
de gendarmerie nouvelle installées
des forces d'action républicaines
mobilisées pour les quartiers les plus
en difficulté
et la sécurité ne l'oubliez jamais c'est
aussi notre justice
c'est pourquoi nous créerons 8500 postes
de magistrats de personnels de justice
pour juger plus vite
en proximité
pour que nulle part il ne puisse plus y
avoir quelqu'un Punité
je ne me résoudrai jamais
jamais comme vous je ne me résoudrai
jamais et je me battrai toujours
oui
et comme nous nous sommes battus sans
relâche durant ces 5 années je veux mes
amis que nous continuions à voir grand
que nous continuions à tenir cette
promesse française de justice de progrès
voilà ce que je voulais en quelques mots
à la cavalcade vous présentez des
progrès concrets que nous avons ensemble
à bâtir
mais tous ces progrès tous ces progrès
du quotidien
qui sont indispensables
ne doivent pas nous faire oublier
quelques grandes causes essentielles
ce que nous avons
sans relâche là aussi
conduit durant ces cinq années
la grande cause de l'égalité entre les
femmes et les hommes
de la lutte contre les violences à
l'égalité salariale
étant étant d'autres combats nous
l'avons mené
nos associations se sont mobilisées mais
nous devrons faire plus nous devrons
faire plus c'est pourquoi à nouveau
l'égalité femme homme sera la grande
cause du quinquennat qui s'ouvre
mener ces grandes batailles de progrès
corriger les inégalités à la racine
permettre l'égalité des chances c'est
cela aussi notre identité
ne pas simplement les corriger
investir dans l'humain en quelque sorte
alors oui
je veux que le deuxième grand combat
ce soit celui pour nos enfants
la protection
la protection de l'enfance
la protection de nos enfants
[Applaudissements]
plusieurs ici même ce combat depuis tant
est tant d'années
et nos enfants si longtemps avaient été
les oubliés les oubliés de nos
politiques publiques
je suis fier avec vous
d'avoir lancé ce qu'on appelle les 1000
premiers jours
ce grand projet
qui depuis l'extension du congé
paternité jusqu'à l'accompagnement des
maires vise à donner les mêmes chances à
chacun quel que soit sa naissance
mais il nous faut au-delà de ce que nous
avons commencé à aller plus loin aller
plus fort
il nous faut protéger nos enfants des
violences qu'il subissent des réseaux
sociaux du harcèlement dont ils sont
trop souvent victimes
protéger
protéger nos enfants de tous ceux qui
dans les silences trop longtemps
tenue
ont commis le pire et continue d'abuser
d'eux
je sais
parce qu'à travers le pays
tant de fois
peut-être quelques-uns d'entre vous qui
sont ici dans cette salle ont interpellé
tirer la Manche pour
me confesser ce qu'ils avaient vécu
avec la honte la honte de la voir vécu
avec la douleur de ne pas pu la voir
de ne pas l'avoir transmis d'en avoir
trouvé
aucune oreille pour l'entendre
aucun adulte pour le recevoir
cette honte là elle changera de quand
cette honte là elle changera de clan
c'est pourquoi
les recommandations de la commission
indépendante sur l'inceste et les
violences sexuelles seront suivies des
faits
notre enjeu sera de bâtir avec les
médecins les enseignants les soignants
les associations une vraie culture
française de la protection de nos
enfants pour prévenir ces violences ces
incestes c'est harcèlement et pour les
guérir pour accompagner pour réparer
nous agirons aussi
pour prémunir les enfants des contenus
de haine qui circulent sur les réseaux
sociaux de ces insultes incessantes qui
vont jusqu'à enlever le vive l'envie de
vivre à certains de nos enfants
la lutte contre le harcèlement sera
accentué avec la mise en place de
délégué dans chaque collège la formation
que nous avons déjà commencé qui sera
renforcée de nos enseignants et
l'extension des numéros et des
plateformes d'appel et le contrôle
parental que nous avons constitué sera
installé par défaut sur chaque appareil
oui
protéger nos enfants
et quand je parle d'enfants bien sûr je
n'oublie pas ce qui sera un immense
combat des années qui viennent ce
troisième grand combat au-delà de tous
les progrès que je vous décrivais celui
de l'éducation
depuis 5 ans nous l'avons donné sans
relâche et je suis fier de notre action
nous tous avec le gouvernement avec les
parlementaires avec vous tout et tous
avec nos enseignants
je suis fier
d'avoir limité à 12 le nombre d'élèves
par classe dans les quartiers
pierre
d'avoir porté les devoirs faits pour les
collégiens quand leurs parents ne
pouvaient pas les accompagner fier
d'avoir permis l'ouverture de 300
internats d'excellence de campus des
métiers d'avoir battu cette école
inclusive fier avec vous de tout cela
mais je suis lucide
l'ascenseur social reste encore trop en
panne
trop de professeurs sont encore
découragés
trop de parents inquiets trop d'élèves
malheureusement
c'est pourquoi nous renforcerons
l'enseignement des savoirs fondamentaux
français mathématiques et ce jusqu'au
baccalauréat
nous généraliserons le sport à l'école
une demi-heure par jour à l'école
primaire dès septembre
car nous devons faire de notre pays
cette grande nation sportive pour la
santé de nos enfants de nos adolescents
du pays
nous renforcerons l'enseignement
artistique et culturel
tout en déployant le Pass Culture au
collège car la culture à l'école
c'est permettre à un enfant à un
adolescent
dans la famille n'a pas de bibliothèque
qu'elle n'a pas pu apprendre
d'accéder au beau à ce qui nous dépasse
ce qui nous donne une raison de vivre
même quand tout semble perdu notre
culture
nous ferons du collège le lieu où l'on
apprend à mieux connaître les métiers et
à s'orienter et nous accompagnerons
mieux les adolescents dans ces moments
charnières en particulier la classe de
6e comme la classe de seconde
nous ferons une révolution complète
complète du lycée professionnel une voie
d'excellence
les enseignants comme les lycéens le
méritent
mais surtout
surtout nous ferons différemment nous
ferons en nous appuyant
sur nos enseignants à qui nous devons
tant et à qui la nation doit tant oui
vous pouvez les applaudir
oui
nos enseignants
ceux qui nous ont parfois par une main
tendue un regard bienveillant permis de
devenir ce que
nous n'étions pas censés devenir ces
artisans de la République
qui permettent à chaque décès à chaque
destin d'enfants parfois de conjurer le
sort nous leur avons tant demandé
quand nous avons voulu rouvrir l'école
le 11 mai 2020 je sais ce que nous leur
avons demandé et je veux ici peut-être
tout particulièrement et tout
personnellement les en remercier
alors
pour leur permettre d'exercer pleinement
leur mission instruire nos enfants et
faire des républicains nos instituteurs
nos professeurs seront mieux rémunérés
et plus libres de proposer
libre d'innove libre d'innover
d'expérimenter comme ils sont tentent à
vouloir le faire d'essayer d'autres
méthodes dans la classe et de pouvoir
les partager libre de leur carrière
libre de choisir un établissement pour
son projet pédagogique singulier et de
s'extraire des mouvements géographiques
qui parfois les assignent à résidence
[Musique]
oui
cette révolution de l'école nous la
ferons avec des chefs d'établissement
eux-mêmes plus libres de bâtir des
projets de conduire des équipes de les
réunir
oui pour ce grand chantier de l'école je
veux que nous donnions enfin aux
enseignants au directrice et directeurs
d'établissements Homère aux parents aux
associations qui s'occupent souvent du
périscolaire à nos enfants eux-mêmes les
moyens de réussir en inventant au plus
près du terrain des solutions adaptées
nouvelles
forte ambitieuse
alors je vous rassure le système nous
dira que c'est impossible on nous
expliquera que ça n'a jamais été fait
qu'il faut faire comme avant discuter
depuis Paris tout décider depuis Paris
mais comme c'est impossible
nous le ferons parce que nous l'avons
déjà fait
[Applaudissements]
fier d'avoir décidé avec les
gouvernements successifs le Ségur pour
des investissements historiques pour
l'hôpital et pour des augmentations
historiques pour le salaire de nos
soignants
[Applaudissements]
mais soyons lucides là aussi
soyons lucides là aussi
sans doute
avons-nous bien fait mais sans doute
était star et nous ne pouvons pas ne pas
regarder en face
l'épuisement de tant de soignants et
j'ai une pensée pour eux
ému mobiliser parce qu'il continue de se
battre dans les hôpitaux dans leur
cabinet pas simplement contre le covid
qui continue à sévir contre les formes
de covid long et contre toutes les
maladies que nous ne pouvons pas oublier
applaudissez nos soignants
mais nuls l'ignore leur épuisement
parfois la perte de sens parce que trop
de postes manquent il manque pourquoi
parce qu'il y a eu des découragements
parce que les vacataires c'est vrai
est-ce que vous dites on trop souvent
été pris mais parce que les emplois
pérennes n'étaient pas assez bien payés
ou parfois pas pourvu parce que le
système c'est bloqué lui-même sur ses
incohérences soyons clairs sur parfois
la bureaucratisation les règles devenues
absurdes donc oui nous devons aller plus
loin pour notre santé
parce qu'aujourd'hui nous avons à la
fois la perte de sens du côté des
soignants et les pertes de chance du
côté des patients
avec ce qu'on appelle les déserts
médicaux dans tant de nos campagnes
d'entendre nos quartiers nos
compatriotes ne trouvent plus les soins
apportés de rendez-vous
d'entendre nos campagnes d'entendre nos
quartiers y compris parmi les plus âgés
les plus vulnérables et ne trouve plus
de médecin c'est une réalité
c'est déserts médicaux on sait ce que ça
produit de l'inégalité de l'inégalité
devant la maladie parce qu'on sait
comment ça se passe on renonce un
rendez-vous parce qu'il n'y a pas de
consultation possible puis un deuxième
et puis ce qui aurait pu être arrêté ou
prévenu
les pertes de chance c'est cela ce que
nous vivons et l'inégalité en matière de
santé ne pourra être combattue
que si précisément
nous arrivons à conjurer ces déserts
médicaux
c'est contre cela
contre ces inégalités
d'accès aux soins indignes indigne de
nous que nous agirons
c'est pour cela d'abord que nous
développerons la prévention nous avons
déjà mis en place
des diagnostics on appelle 10 pour nos
jeunes enfants
nous avons mis en place des diagnostics
dont nous sommes si fiers à juste titre
en particulier pour détecter plutôt les
différentes formes d'autisme chez nos
enfants et chez les plus jeunes
et en disant cela
la salle c'est clair de ce bleu qui va
avec en effet ce jour de l'autisme nous
nous sommes et je veux ici
que nous pensions
que nous pensions à tous nos
compatriotes
qui sont
atteints d'autisme quel qu'en soit la
forme
qui vivent au milieu de nous avec nous
avec nous et dont nous sommes fiers
et je veux dire alors famille à leurs
enseignants à leurs accompagnants alors
soignants
que nous en sommes fiers
alors nous continuerons en la prévention
les diagnostics à 25 ans à 40 ans à 60
ans qui seront prises en charge par la
sécurité sociale parce qu'investir sur
le diagnostic à ces âges critiques de la
vie c'est permettre de prévenir tant et
tant de maladies
c'est un investissement dans l'humain
mais un investissement rentable aussi
bien moins coûteux que d'aller ensuite
guérir trop tard
et nous agirons avec force pour faire
reculer ces déserts médicaux
partout où je me déplace
d'Aulnay à Amiens depuis Guillaume à
Mulhouse
de Martel à Tours
on en parle alors il n'y a pas de
recette miracle dans la matière on le
sait bien
il y a le bon sens et la volonté le bon
sens et la volonté
de permettre à des infirmiers des
infirmières à des pharmaciens et des
pharmaciens
de pouvoir dégager nos médecins de
certaines tâches de faire eux davantage
pour que nos médecins puissent prendre
plus de patients
il y a le bon sens et la volonté qui
consiste à dire que les gares ne sont
peut-être pas un mauvais système et
d'ailleurs il se trouve qu'on n'est pas
pour moins malade la nuit où les
week-ends
mais qu'il faut peut-être nous
réorganiser sur les territoires savoir
les payer justement mais retrouver sur
chaque territoire une offre de soins
continue le bon sens et la volonté qui
doivent nous conduire à redonner plus de
responsabilités à l'hôpital aux
soignants à changer la gouvernance de
nos hôpitaux
à décloisonner entre l'hôpital et la
médecine de ville nos organisations à
permettre à des jeunes médecins qui
veulent s'installer d'être salariés
encore davantage de travailler un peu à
l'hôpital et un peu à la ville
d'inventer sur le territoire au plus
près les solutions innovantes et de le
faire là aussi avec nos élus qui
connaissent ces problématiques
en lien avec eux de le faire entre
médecins paramedicaux associations de
patients
citoyens
le bon sens et la volonté consiste à
dire que si nous voulons qu'à la fin de
leurs études de jeunes médecins
s'installent en zone rurale ou dans les
quartiers les plus difficiles nous
pouvons en créer les conditions voilà
voilà ce qui nous reviendra de
construire ensemble
et là aussi
pas de manière uniforme pas depuis Paris
non sur le terrain
en redonnant de la liberté du pouvoir
au niveau de l'hôpital au service et au
niveau d'un territoire et des objectifs
qui sont définis là où les gens vivent
là où les besoins sont connus ou les
solutions sont bâties
oui mes amis
oui mes amis je vous rassure malgré vos
applaudissements là aussi le système
viendra nous dire que c'est impossible
et nous le ferons
alors
je vous rassure
je viens de vous parler là de nos
progrès de chaque jour des nouvelles
conquêtes que nous voulons faire de ces
quatre grandes causes que nous allons
porter sur lesquels nous allons nous
battre et innover
mais pour y arriver pour financer cela
il n'y a pas d'argent magique
et j'ai une mauvaise nouvelle il n'y en
a pas davantage aujourd'hui il y en
avait il y a 5 ans
et donc
moi je préfère être clair
pour financer tout cela il n'y aura pas
de hausse d'impôts non
nous les baisserons
et je peux vous le dire
avec crédibilité car nous l'avons fait
durant 5 ans
pour financer cela
il n'y aura pas de hausse de notre dette
non
la dette comme tous les autres pays nous
en avons constitué une durant la période
du covid il fallait le faire elle est là
et nous la rembourserons dans le temps
en l'amortissant sur plusieurs décennies
mais notre dette celle qui dépendent nos
déficits courants nous devons elle y
répondre c'est pourquoi nous tiendrons
nos objectifs nous nous y attaquerons
parce que nous ne pouvons laisser à nos
enfants une dette qui aura augmenté à
partir de 2026 nous la baisserons
non tout ce que je viens de vous décrire
nous ne le ferons qu'en travaillant
davantage
qu'en produisant c'est ça la vérité
et c'est cela qui a toujours été notre
film directeur durant ces cinq dernières
années alors
parfois c'est agréable à entendre
parfois ça n'est pas agréable à entendre
je sais
mais oui
il n'y a pas d'état social il n'y a pas
d'état Providence s'il n'y a pas un état
productif fort s'il n'y a pas une France
qui invente qui produit qui travaille
qui crée de la richesse pour pouvoir la
redistribuer
on le reprendra pas le contrôle de nos
vies du progrès
s'il n'y a pas tout cela alors j'assume
oui de vous dire qu'il faudra travailler
plus
et d'abord travailler plus longtemps
parce que nous vivons plus vieux
et oui
comme l'ont déjà fait l'Italie l'Espagne
l'Allemagne tant de nos voisins il
faudra de manière concertée bien sûr de
manière progressive et visible passer
l'âge de notre retraite à 65 ans
parce que c'est ainsi d'abord que nous
pourrons financer tous les progrès que
j'évoquais que notre relation sera plus
forte nous le ferons de manière
progressive avec des mesures de justice
que nous voulons forte mais c'est la
condition et c'est la condition d'abord
pour consolider notre modèle de retraite
par répartition cette solidarité entre
les génération
et c'est la condition pour améliorer nos
pensions
alors je vous le dis
ne croyez pas ceux qui vous expliquent
qu'ils feront la retraite à 60 ans ou à
62 ans d'ailleurs on est plus tellement
au clair et que tout ira bien ça n'est
pas vrai
et travailler plus
c'est aussi travailler plus nombreux
j'assume oui
de viser l'objectif du plein emploi
car grâce à tout ce que nous avons fait
ensemble durant ces cinq années pour la
première fois depuis le milieu des
années 70 notre pays peut dire dans les
5 années qui viennent qu'il atteindra le
plein emploi oui c'est possible
voilà pourquoi
nous continuerons de mener les réformes
indispensables sur l'assurance chômage
pour le marché du travail voilà pourquoi
nous continuerons de mener plus de plus
de liberté
à tous nos entrepreneurs voilà pourquoi
aussi nous mettrons en place pour les
bénéficiaires du RSA de 15 à 20h par
semaine des activités de formation
d'insertion de réinsertion
sur le modèle de ce que nous faisons
depuis le 1er mars avec le contrat
d'engagement jeune pour les 18-25 ans
il ne s'agit pas comme l'ont prétendu
certains de travaux d'intérêt général
non
encore moins de vouloir couper des aides
à ceux que la vie a trop abîmée pour
exercer une activité et qui auront
toujours droit de manière
inconditionnelle il s'agit tout
simplement
de tendre la main et d'offrir à tous les
bénéficiaires du RSA des perspectives un
espoir la possibilité de faire et
enfin de bien faire comme plusieurs déjà
le fond dans leur département ou dans
leur commune le travail d'accompagnement
de réinsertion qui fait que toute
personne qui n'a plus de travail qui est
en fin de droite et qui n'a même plus
son chômage et malgré tout un citoyen
qui a le droit d'être accompagné pour
pouvoir réapprendre retrouver des
perspectives et retourner vers l'emploi
nous le ferons car la France est une
nation solidaire une nation humaine une
nation qui ne laisse personne au bord du
chemin mes amis mes amis
le travail au service du progrès voilà
ce qui nous tient voilà ce qui nous fait
nation c'est pourquoi oui c'est par le
travail par la production que durant ces
5 années qui viennent nous pourrons
augmenter notre croissance crée plus de
richesses et pouvoir continuer le
progrès
l'humanisme au service du progrès voilà
ce qui nous unit voilà pourquoi nous
nous battons un humanisme qui part du
réel qui regarde les difficultés en face
assume les choix à faire mais ne cède
jamais rien de son idéal
travail
humanisme progrès voilà ce que nous
voulons faire ensemble voilà ce qui nous
rend si fier si fier d'être français
[Applaudissements]
je m'appelle Biry ta Nathalie
je m'appelle Johan
je m'appelle Sandrine croatteau et je
suis professeur des écoles je m'appelle
Pierre mallise je suis le gérant jardin
pêcheur de Bordeaux je m'appelle Patrick
Hudelot je suis viticulteur je m'appelle
Laurence Paganini je dirige caporal
depuis 8 ans je m'appelle lona et je
suis infirmière
on est formé pour ça pour gérer la crise
pour gérer l'urgence
il est très dur mais de tout petit ils
avaient ça dans la peau contrairement à
ce que l'on pense les Français sont très
sensibles à la question du handicap
[Musique]
je pense que c'est une aventure humaine
parce que la finalité c'est créer de
l'emploi et de faire vivre son
territoire
pour moi être vigneront c'est un métier
de passion c'était un métier
d'engagement et il y a tellement
d'affaires tellement affaire donc pour
tous les courageux tous ceux qui ont
envie de la nature allez-y il y a de la
place
je suis professeur des écoles en classe
dédoubler CE1 ma classe c'est une classe
qui a aménagé pour faciliter les
apprentissages en fonction des besoins
et des rythmes des enfants
j'ai contribué à l'épanouissement des
enfants qui vont devenir des futurs
citoyens
si je vous parle aujourd'hui c'est parce
que mon fils est décédé lors d'Éric et
je souhaiterais que cela s'arrête
les genoux on compte sur vous ne baissez
pas les bras baisser les couteaux et
[Musique]
merci Nathalie
mes amis
nous sommes pas tout à fait les mêmes
qu'en 2017
niveau ni moi il y en a qui ont toujours
autant d'énergie
et vous
mais c'est ça
c'est 5 années nous savons ont été rude
pour nous tous et pour certains sirudes
c'est injuste
elles ont été à coup sûr parmi
les plus bouleversantes que nous ayons
connues depuis un domicile
et je suis là aujourd'hui
avec vous au milieu de vous
[Musique]
et pas un jour
et pas un jour de ces 5 années
je n'ai oublié
vos visages vous voyez tout à l'heure
vos regards
ces regards parfois si amicaux si
affectueux quelquefois aussi
interrogatives
je le sais d'autres fois en colère aussi
et quand nous nous croisons je regarde
toujours vos yeux vous le savez je
touche souvent les bras aussi je sais
et quand on est
le responsable qu'on est celui à qui
forcément on demande des comptes
c'est une chance incroyable que d'être
accompagné
par les regards
de ceux qui vous ont choisi comme par
les regards de ceux qui ne vous ont pas
choisi
alors je veux
je veux vous remercier tous militants
élus engagé depuis tant d'années à mes
côtés
je vous remercier tous
je veux avoir un mot plus particulier
pour mes compagnons de fortune et
d'infortune
leur affection
et leur présence m'ont été chaque jour
si précieuses alors chacune et chacun à
son style certains pénétrables d'autres
passionnés certains militants
de bons caractères ou de moins bons
caractères
il y a ceux qui montent à l'assaut ceux
qui ont le silence des sages
mais je veux leur dire
à tous et toutes
que sans eux
je n'aurais pas pu faire ce chemin
et malheureusement
quelques-unes et quelques-uns qui ne
sont plus là
mais il y a tous ceux compagnons de nuit
d'échanges et de travail
chef de gouvernement membre de
gouvernement compagnons de lutte
politique
parlementaire
équipe
à tous
je veux qu'il sache
[Applaudissements]
la place qu'ils ont prises à mes côtés
je ne le dis pas je le sais suffisamment
je le dis parfois mal
mais de celles et ceux des premiers
combats impossibles jusqu'à celles et
ceux
qui ont rejoint ces dernières semaines
qui sont là celles et ceux dont les
nuits
non plus exister qu'il travaille à mes
côtés
au mouvement ailleurs merci
et je pense aussi
à celles et ceux qui n'ont pas pu être
là ce soir mais je vais venir ne vous
inquiétez pas
je vais venir ne vous inquiétez pas
[Applaudissements]
et j'ai une pensée aussi pour celles et
ceux qui ne sont pas là ce soir à nos
côtés
mais dans les vides de combat
nous permettent d'être là
je veux que ma famille
mes parents
nos enfants
nos petits-enfants
mes frères et sœurs tous ceux à qui je
fais vivre depuis tant d'années
des vies de contraintes qu'ils n'ont pas
choisi je veux leur dire simplement ma
reconnaissance et mon affection merci
et puis
vous savez tous
sans qu'il soit besoin d'en dire plus
la présence
de celle qui m'importe le plus qui
m'apporte le plus
dans cette singulière aventure de vie
Brigitte
alors oui
pouvons-nous être vraiment les mêmes
qu'il y a 5 ans
après avoir
décidé à quelques-uns de confiner tout
un pays pour tenter de sauver des vies
qui pouvaient l'être
pouvons-nous être les mêmes
quand on a eu à regarder dans les yeux
des familles de nos soldats morts Mali
pour notre liberté
lorsque nous avons connu la décapitation
d'un professeur Samuel Paty par la
conspiration funeste de la folie des
hommes et de l'idéologie terroriste
islamique
[Applaudissements]
et sa famille
non nous ne sommes plus les mêmes
face au retour de la guerre en Europe au
martyrs de Mario Paul
assez fans à ses enfants Ukrainiens qui
laissent toute leur vie derrière eux
fuis les armes et attendent le cœur
serré des nouvelles de leur mari de leur
père et merci merci à tant de familles
attends de nos communes de les
accueillir sur notre sol c'est notre
devoir
oui
le monde de paix que nous avions fini
par croire éternel
le monde
de marche en avant continue du progrès
que nous avions fini par croire
inébranlable
tout cela semble se défaire sous nos
yeux oui ce que nous vivons c'est une
forme de grande dérèglement
dérèglement du vivant avec une épidémie
qui n'est d'un virus passé de l'animal à
l'homme nous a ramené aux méthodes du
Moyen-Âge parfois
dérèglement écologique avec le
réchauffement climatique l'érosion de la
biodiversité et la multiplication des
catastrophes dérèglement du capitalisme
avec la montée d'inégalités
insupportable générant tension et
division dans nos sociétés
dérèglement
géopolitique avec le retour
des guerres des rêves d'Empire et le
spectre peut-être d'un conflit armée
global
dérèglement enfin des consciences quand
le religieux nourrit la haine et les
meurtres quand l'universalisme se
fracasse sur le complotisme quand les
réseaux sociaux isolent plutôt qu'il ne
libère
oui grand dérèglement
alors
face à ce retour du tragique dans
l'histoire
nous ne sommes pas nous
de
ceux qui attisent les peurs et recherche
des boucs émissaires ça ne sert à rien
nous ne sommes pas
nous ne sommes pas non plus de ce qui
nous résignent nous nous battons mais
nous nous battons avec l'esprit critique
le goût de l'universalisme l'amour de la
vérité
car nous pensons que les crises sont des
moments d'accélération de
cristallisation ou soudain ce qui
semblait impossible devient possible ou
paradoxalement il est possible de faire
avancer des progrès immenses
nous l'avons fait d'ailleurs pendant la
pandémie rappelez-vous notre Europe a
connu une avancée inédite en mutualisant
une dette à venir pour financer ce que
nous n'avions pas quelques mois plus tôt
nous l'avons fait
là aussi au moment de la pandémie quand
nous avons redécouvert ensemble
l'importance de la production
industrielle de la souveraineté
industrielle sur notre sol et que nous
avons relocalisé
alors oui
nous pensons que les crises sont des
moments où ceux qui savent loin pensent
le temps long font preuve d'optimisme
peuvent initier des changements d'époque
voilà notre ambition
[Musique]
et ce changement d'époque mes amis
il se fera par l'Europe il se fera par
la France
c'est pourquoi
c'est pourquoi nous ne lâcherons rien de
notre combat pour l'idéal européen
oui
qui mieux qui mieux que l'Europe qui a
su vacciner sa population en un temps
record mettre en place un plan de
relance historique se montrer généreuse
et exporter donner ses vaccins pour
faire face aux crises qui viennent
qui
qui mieux que l'Europe pour s'immiscer
dans le duopole qui s'installe entre les
États-Unis et la Chine
qui
qui mieux que notre Europe
ce petit bout de terre qui a inventé
l'humanisme les lumières pour faire
émerger un modèle de régulation
d'Internet qui chassent les discours de
complot de haine de désinformation pour
défendre l'esprit critique la liberté de
la presse
ce combat
c'est celui que notre président est en
train de porter en faisant adopter grâce
au Parlement européen deux textes
historiques en la matière et nous
continuerons
qui qui mieux que notre Europe ce petit
bout de terre qui a inventé l'État
providence pour encadrer le capitalisme
lutter contre les inégalités comme nous
avons commencé à le faire en obtenant en
européen la mise en place d'un impôt
minimal sur les sociétés pour éviter
l'évasion fiscale
en Europe 1
oui ces derniers jours j'ai entendu
parler beaucoup d'évasion fiscale
et de cabinets américains
bon
simplement je voulais rappeler à tous
ceux qui sont d’années qui sont Nadine
qui les ont à chaque fois utilisés dans
leur collectivité au gouvernement
mais
surtout
s'indigner contre l'absence d'un pot
minimal vouloir se battre vouloir se
battre contre l'évasion fiscale on ne le
sait pas en français ce n'est pas vrai
parce que l'entreprise contre laquelle
on se bat et va s'installer en Belgique
elle va s'installer à nos frontières
elle délocalise mais elle continue de
séduire
ces gens-là n'ont donc plus compris
comment le monde fonctionnait non il
faut pas simplement s'indigner il faut
agir l'impôt minimal en européen nous
nous sommes battus nous l'avons fait et
c'est un pot minimal c'est celui qui
sera que toutes les sociétés
internationales devront payer un minimum
d'impôts là où de la valeur est créée en
européen car c'est ainsi qu'il faut agir
qui qui mieux que notre Europe
pour bâtir avec la rive-sud de la
Méditerranée une nouvelle alliance
d'investissement et de solidarité notre
Méditerranée que nous aimons tant
doit redevenir un continent d'ambition
de culture d'échanges oui c'est par
l'alliance entre l'Europe et l'Afrique
que nous le ferons
qui qui mieux que l'Europe
pour répondre à la crise alimentaire
mondiale qui est en train de commencer à
cause de la guerre
plusieurs pays du Caucase au Proche et
Moyen-Orient jusqu'à l'Afrique sont en
train de manquer c'est en européen par
l'Europe que nous répondrons à cette
crise qui vient qui qui mieux que
l'Europe pour réussir la neutralité
carbone en 2050
pour entraîner les nations du monde dans
le combat climatique le combat du siècle
et je suis fier que notre pays était
parmi les premiers au printemps 2018 à
avoir porté cette ambition européenne de
la neutralité carbone 2050 nous y sommes
tous et nous le ferons
qui
qui mieux que l'Europe pour protéger nos
frontières en engageant une refondation
de l'espace Schengen en préservant
l'asile véritable pour accueillir les
combattants de la liberté que nous
devons accueillir et protéger et en
combattant les mafia qui font trafic des
êtres humains en luttant contre
l'immigration clandestine
sur ce sujet nous n'avons aucune leçon à
recevoir nous avons doublé nos forces de
sécurité intérieure aux frontières pour
les protéger nous avons parfois même
mobilisé notre armée quand c'était
nécessaire
nous avons agi en européen pour démonter
les filières mais si nous voulons aller
plus loin et nous le ferons alors oui il
nous faut engager une simplification
drastique de nos procédures rendre notre
politique de lutte contre l'immigration
clandestine plus efficace mais en
européen bâtir ce nouvel espace de
protection et de sécurité
qui mieux que l'Europe qui sait combien
les guerres emportent de souffrance
indélébile pour nous protéger du retour
des empires
l'Europe sera là pour assurer notre
indépendance au travers d'une défense
commune et repensée un ordre
international nouveau
les amis nous étions les seuls en 2017
a agité les drapeaux européens
nous avons été critiqués
quand nous avons mis le drapeau européen
sous l'Arc de Triomphe et bien nous
l'assumons
et aujourd'hui encore vous le voyez et
pour les 5 années qui viennent nous
sommes fiers d'être européens
de brandir la bannière bleue étoilée aux
côtés de notre drapeau national
et bon courage à ceux qui fassent à la
Russie prône le grand repli et bon
courage à ceux qui fassent au retour des
empires et aux défis des temps défendre
le grand rabougrissement
nous continuerons
à nous engager
pour que notre Europe avance
mais mes amis
notre Europe avancera mais rien
rien de tout cela
rien de tout cela n'est possible
rien ne pourra se faire sans la France
sans raviver la flamme
de cet esprit si singulier quel esprit
français
face à ceux qui veulent asservir les
peuples étouffer les consciences faire
taire les différences
il n'y a pas plus puissant en effet
que la force inspirante de la liberté
face à un monde fou ou la naissance
détermine trop souvent les destins ou
les succès ne se construisent pas assez
par le mérite mais par l'héritage où les
milliards vont encore trop souvent au
milliard et la pauvreté trop souvent à
la pauvreté il n'y a pas plus puissant
que le goût de l'égalité
face à ceux qui tentent de semer le
poison de la division de fragmenter de
fracturer les hommes il n'y a pas plus
puissant que la force tranquille de la
fraternité
face
aux fanatisme islamistes qui sème la
mort face aux séparatisme qui veut
installer dans la République la règle de
quelques-uns et le règne du plus fort il
n'y a pas plus puissant que la vigueur
apaisée de la laïcité
liberté
égalité
fraternité laïcité
je suis sûr d'une chose mes amis
je suis sûr d'une chose
c'est que nos valeurs
sont les meilleures réponses au défi des
temps elles sont profondément modernes
liberté
égalité fraternité
laïcité je suis sûr d'une chose
c'est que ces valeurs
ne sont pas des acquis non elles doivent
être défendues sans relâche elles sont
une conquête de chaque matin je suis sûr
d'une chose c'est que nos valeurs ne
vivront que si la France est forte
indépendante puissante
voilà pourquoi
voilà pourquoi notre projet est aussi un
projet
d'indépendant et de puissance française
oui
pour pouvoir porter ses valeurs pour
nous-mêmes et pour le monde
puissance militaire d'abord après un
effort budgétaire inédit depuis 2017
nous continuerons d'investir pour nos
armées à la fois pour améliorer la vie
du soldat
son équipement pour assurer notre
dissuasion pour financer et matérielle
les plus innovants nos armées
nous généraliserons le service national
universel
et réaffirmeront le lien armé nation
notre objectif est clair nous préparer
dans le nouveau contexte que nous vivons
à affronter une guerre qui peut être
venir et nous préparer aussi à toutes
les nouvelles menaces du cyber aux
nouvelles conflictualités maritimes ou
spatiale
puissance diplomatique de paix et
d'équilibre aussi c'est parce que la
France à son histoire ce modèle d'armée
complète sa place dans le concert des
nations que nous pouvons jouer ce rôle
je le dis ici avec beaucoup de clarté
nous sommes une nation européenne fier
de l'être
bâtissant en Europe notre ambition
et nous nous sommes les vassaux de
personnes nous poursuivrons donc une
politique
et une diplomatie indépendante
[Musique]
assumant de parler à tout le monde tout
le temps
oui je l'assume
le rôle de la France
et de ne pas céder
au grand clivage qui paralyse
mais de savoir échanger avec chaque
région chaque puissance de continuer à
bâtir des alliances nouvelles de l'Indo
pacifique au Proche et Moyen-Orient de
continuer à agir pour inventer des
solutions pour le Liban tant aimé
l'Arménie si proche
[Musique]
de continuer
à oeuvrer pour bâtir ce nouvel ordre
international
multilatéral qui dans les années qui
viennent devra être repensé
puissance et indépendante
puissance de savoir et de science aussi
nous ne cesserons pas de défendre la
science ouverte nous investirons dans
notre recherche fondamentale comme dans
notre recherche appliquée en modernisant
nos universités nos organismes de
recherche
allons-y nous y sommes prêts nous le
ferons
puissance agricole
car nous ne pouvons pas non plus
dépendre des autres pour nous nourrir
et nos agriculteurs nos agriculteurs qui
nous ont nourris durant la pandémie et
vous pouvez les applaudir
[Musique]
nos agriculteurs continueront d'être là
pour assurer la puissance agricole
française
relevez les nouveaux défis et nous
serons à leur côté pour continuer
d'investir et les accompagner dans cette
troisième révolution agricole conciliant
environnement et production
puissance
puissance d'innovation et puissance
industrielle car il n'y a aucune
fatalité
nous avons en quelques années fait de la
France la grande nation européenne des
start-up
[Applaudissements]
industriels dans notre pays
relocaliser les productions
industrielles
alors nous pouvons dans notre pays dans
les prochaines années faire que les
calculateurs quantiques les objets
connectés les champions de la santé
numérique les véhicules électriques les
champions de l'intelligence artificielle
du cyber les avions 0 carbone les
biomédicaments les petits réacteurs
nucléaires les éoliennes les panneaux
solaires que tout cela puisse être
français et européen
pour tout cela
nous continuerons de baisser les impôts
et d'investir car c'est la clé pour
créer de l'activité et être cette
puissance productive industrielle et
indépendante que nous voulons
puissance écologique oui
en rénovant 700 000 logements par an sur
le quinquennat qui vient
en proposant à chaque Français à chaque
française une offre de location de
voiture électrique à moins de 100 euros
en investissant sur la sobriété
énergétique
en relançant la construction de
réacteurs nucléaires pour notre
indépendance
en planifiant le déploiement de sources
d'énergie renouvelable sur les 20 années
qui viennent pour notre indépendance et
mettre moins
oui
nous deviendrons
la première grande nation à sortir des
énergies fossiles nous le pouvons nous
le ferons
en accompagnant les grandes transitions
d'usage vers les produits recyclés
réutilisés en protégeant nos écosystèmes
sur terre comme en mer nous pourrons
devenir une puissance de l'économie
circulaire et de la biodiversité
[Applaudissements]
puissance culturelle oui aussi surtout
que de grandes multinationales puis
s'imposer leurs règles parfois bafouer
le droit d'auteur
remettent en cause la création française
une certaine manière de penser le monde
nous ne l'accepterons jamais
alors oui
oui
nous porterons ce combat pour
l'exception culturelle ce combat qui est
le nôtre oui
nous continuerons le combat pour les
droits d'auteur et les droits voisins le
combat qui fut cette intuition géniale
de Beaumarchais cette conviction de
Genevois puis de Malraux nous l'avons
défendu mener renforcer en européen là
aussi
oui
continuez de faire de la France une
puissance de culture c'est défendre nos
auteurs notre création c'est permettre
de bâtir un métavère français européen
qui ne dépendent pas des normes des
codes imposés par d'autres mais c'est
permettre de continuer de créer d'avoir
notre imaginaire de continuer de porter
notre singularité une certaine idée de
l'homme
oui les amis c'est ainsi
par la France par cette puissance que
nous pourrons être ce que nous avons
toujours été notre vocation une
puissance de rêve
alors mes amis ne vous trompez pas
faire tout cela bâtir une France
indépendante dans une Europe puissante
n'a rien d'une évidence
nul ne nous attend
ni les empires qui veulent revenir ni
les grands groupes privés qui voudraient
diriger à la Place des Nations
ensuite
parce que bâtir la puissance construire
l'indépendance
suppose que nous retrouvions que
effectivement le goût du courage
oui le goût du courage
et fort immense
tant le matérialisme est devenu
l'idéologie dominante la course effrénée
au confort le rythme comme naturel de
nos sociétés contemporaines
efforts crucial pourtant
si nous voulons affronter l'époque
il nous faut renouer avec cette part de
devoirs cette part d'efforts cette force
d'âme
comporte la citoyenneté française
il nous faut renouer avec une forme de
spiritualité française voilà pourquoi je
tiens tant de puis cinq ans à célébrer
nos héros passés et récents
parce que leur exemple doit nous guider
en particulier dans le moment historique
que nous vivons
notre France notre France est le visage
de Maurice Genevoix et de ceux de 14
parties dans les tranchées
comme le firent nos arrières
grands-parents notre France notre France
a le visage
de Daniel Cordier Hubert Germain dernier
compagnon de la Libération qui a 17 ans
17 ans
pour rejoindre le général de Gaulle
gagner Londres et défendre la France
Libre notre France a le visage de
Joséphine Baker
qui renonça au confort de la vie de
vedette pour entrer en résistance et
défier la mort pour des valeurs plus
grandes que soi notre France
est le visage de Simone Veil
qui réchappa descendages vite et trouva
malgré tout en elle la force de faire
avancer la cause des femmes et consacrer
sa vie à la défense de l'idéal européen
notre France a le visage d'Arnaud
Beltrame victime de l'île islamiste à
Trèbes qui se sacrifia pour sauver ses
compatriotes
notre France a le visage de Cédric de
Pierrepont et Alain Berthoud c'est l'eau
envoyée au combat pour sauver des otages
et dont la bravoure dans le sacrifice on
aura le destin du soldat
et s'il nous faut nous inspirer du
courage de tous ces héros les amis
alors nous le ferons
nous le ferons pour nous-mêmes
et nous le ferons pour le monde
car la France
n'est pas n'importe quelle nation
regarder
tout ce qui aspirent à vivre libre tous
les opprimés pour la France est une
espérance car oui la France c'est le
peuple de Pathé du nom de cette bataille
de 1429 ou à quelques milliers des
cavaliers mir fin des décennies
d'occupation ennemies la France c'est le
peuple de 1789 qui proclama un jour
doute la fin des privilèges pour
lui-même et pour l'humanité entière la
France
c'est le peuple des Glières
de ces 465 résistants qui ont défendu la
liberté sur les cimes enneigées des
Alpes seules contre tous
oui
nous sommes cette lueur d'espoir
nous sommes cette lueur d'espoir qui ne
fait jamais même lorsque tout semble
perdu ce pays qui même dans les temps
les plus troubles
ne cèdent jamais rien de son idéal c'est
cela à la fin la France la flamme de la
résistance
la force de l'espérance
une singularité qui inspire une
générosité qui emporte la France au fond
ce sont des moments de bravoure
et quelques mots d'amour
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
alors mes amis enfin pour bâtir tout
cela et relever nos défis
il nous faudra savoir bâtir notre unité
combat difficile tant les forces de
division sont nombreuses qui opposent
les Français les uns aux autres ceux qui
sont nés en France et les autres
les plus modestes au plus riches les
urbains aux ruraux les musulmans pour
lesquels le ramadan commence en ce jour
aux autres croyances
et combats nécessaires si nous ne
voulons pas diluer notre force dans nos
divisions
depuis 2017
nous n'avons cessé d'agir pour une
France unie et cette tâche est comme
sans fin mais je l'assume
je me suis souvent demandé
au fond ce que
ce qui était dans notre pays
au plus profond de lui-même être
président
ce que ça signifie
depuis tout à l'heure je défends tant de
projet tant de progrès tant de bataille
que je pourrais vous dire chacune
d'entre elles
c'est d'essayer de vrai je crois
profondément pour qu'à chaque instant
tous nos compatriotes
se souviennent pourquoi ils vivent
ensemble et sont unis c'est cela s'il
n'y avait qu'une fonction
alors notre unité
nous la bâtirons en mobilisant nos
forces à travers les crises nous l'avons
vécu les crises réunissent
et je veux que nous puissions dans la
durée tenir cette unité c'est pourquoi
je veux pour les 5 ans qui viennent un
grand plan de mobilisation citoyenne et
civique qui permettra de mobiliser
beaucoup plus le service civique les
réserves citoyennes et de recenser les
compétences de chacun d'enregistrer les
capacités de nos entreprises les stocks
stratégiques
c'est unité c'est la lutte contre les
discriminations que nous allons
amplifier
car la France unie
c'est celle qui se regardent en face
dans sa pluralité
la France unise est celle qui sait que
renoncer à lutter contre les
discriminations seraient retranchés une
part d'elle-même
notre unité c'est aussi le travail de
reconnaissance
d'histoire pour toutes les mémoires et
souffrances de notre passé comme nous
l'avons fait patiemment ensemble
pour toutes les mémoires de la guerre
d'Algérie comme du génocide rwandais
notre unité
c'est notre patrimoine culturel et
naturel pour lesquels nous ne cessons
d'investir pour préserver restaurer
notre unité
c'est de continuer
à nous voir tels que nous sommes
ce pays monde
dont les contours disent la vocation
universelle cette archipel unique qui
s'étend
sur tous les continents grâce à nos
outre-mer
nos outre-mer
grâce auxquels nous sommes un trésor de
biodiversité
et la plus grande puisse la deuxième
puissance maritime mondiale
et je ne peux pas ici avoir une pensée
fraternelle
pour tous nos compatriotes de nouvelles
Calédonie qui après trois référendum on
choisit la France
[Musique]
notre unité c'est notre langue langue de
liberté langue de l'universelangue
rayonnante aux quatre coins du monde
pour laquelle nous avons bâti cette Cité
internationale de la langue française et
de la Francophonie là où tout a commencé
un Villers-Cotterêts
pour en faire un lieu
d'hospitalité et de transmission de
création de notre francophonie oui
face à tous ces défis
l'unité de la France est essentielle une
unité forte de nos différences de
singularité
assumant notre histoire à travers tous
les continents et embrassant toute notre
diaspora
car la France
la France est un bloc fait de temps
étant d'affluents c'est un bloc fait de
tente et tant de différence mais qui
aspire à l'universel et défend
l'universel la France c'est un bloc et
on ne trie pas on ne choisit pas on
l'aime tout entière on la prend comme
elle est
notre France c'est notre langue notre
culture notre état notre volonté commune
et c'est cette unité que je veux pour
nous dans les 5 ans qui viennent pour
agir pour bâtir pour rassembler et mener
tous les projets dont je viens de vous
parler cela
alors
il nous faudra une méthode nouvelle
je l'ai esquissé à la cavalcade en
présentant chacun des grands chantiers
cette méthode nouvelle
j'y crois profondément et je pense
qu'elle correspond à l'aspiration de
tous nos compatriotes nous l'avons vécu
au moment de la crise des gilets jaunes
lorsque nous avons ensemble innové du
grand débat aux conventions citoyennes
aux grandes réformes il y a une volonté
d'être associée de participer d'agir je
l'ai senti chez nos mère nos élus locaux
qui ne veulent plus que les instructions
tombent de Paris qui
considèrent que la bureaucratie c'est
quand la norme est toujours la même
trop compliqué ne laissant pas place aux
différences
associées c'est reconnaître le rôle de
toutes les parties prenantes des
associations des bénévoles qui jouent en
rôle si fondamental dans notre pays mais
c'est faire que celles et ceux qui
agissent
puissent aussi décider et faire pour
eux-mêmes et ces grands chantiers de
l'école ou de la santé que j'évoquais
tout à l'heure ce sont aussi des
méthodes radicalement de faire
différentes oui ce que je veux que nous
puissions bâtir c'est au fond en
quelques mois
de définir les grands axes les objectifs
et les moyens que nous mettrons et de
donner la liberté sur le terrain
d'apporter les réponses de le faire
autour des élus qui savent le faire dès
qu'il y a une crise nous l'avons vu dès
qu'il y a une crise des inondations des
incendies que se passe-t-il on n'attend
pas la circulaire qui descend pour agir
nos pompiers nos forces de sécurité
intérieure nos militaires sont à
l'action formidables nos élus réagissent
avec leurs équipes
mais nous savons faire sans contrainte
parce que l'intelligence collective est
là qui réagit invente
cette méthode
je crois que c'est celle que nous devons
ensemble collectivement inventer c'est
pourquoi vous l'avez compris avec vous
n'est pas simplement
un slogan
c'est une méthode profonde exigeante à
laquelle je me livrerai mais comme vous
le constatez pour ceux qui en doutez
l'énergie est encore là et à laquelle
et à laquelle
le gouvernement les administrations se
livreront c'est une réforme de l'État
profonde inédite à laquelle je crois
profondément elle ne passe pas par des
textes compliqués par des grandes lois
par des grands décrets c'est une réforme
de méthode de culture radicale je crois
que c'est celle à laquelle notre pays
aspire nous le ferons
et Associés cette méthode c'est aussi
celle que je veux
dans le champ politique nos élus nos
parlementaires les membres du
gouvernement qui sont là toutes les
formations politiques et les bénévoles
le savent c'est l'histoire qui est la
nôtre c'est ce à quoi je crois pour
notre pays
d'abord nous avons créé une formation
politique nouvelle
elle ne venait pas de nulle part elle
était la convergence de tant et tant de
volonté
les uns venaient de gauche du centre de
la droite
de l'écologie politique de la société
civile certains avaient eu plusieurs
mandats d'autres n'en avaient jamais eu
le centre politique nous a ensuite
rejoint
puis des personnalités politiques
nos gouvernement se sont nourris de
talents venant tous horizons et les deux
premiers ministres ici présents chez
Edouard cherchant
les deux premiers ministres je le dis
parce que
souvent les médias oublient
aucun d'eux n'était à mes côtés il y a 5
ans
et c'est une réalité et beaucoup de
ministres n'ont plus mais nous l'avons
fait nous avons agi dépassé et ils ont
mis et les jours et les nuits en
œuvre un projet qui était porté par
d'autres il y a 5 ans
mais ils l'ont rejoint porter avec
conviction et nous avons continué de
dépasser et je sais combien chers
Richard chers-françois cherche Stanislas
chers Christophe vous tant d'autres
soldat de la première heure vous avez
considéré que ce dépassement était
important et qui nous fallait poursuivre
et bien nous allons continuer de le
faire et le dépassement politique
n'est pas l'effacement des différences
il se nourrit en profondeur des
inspirations de chacune et chacun
se cite les grands auteurs je suis
inspiré
le dépassement politique
c'est l'union pour notre pays au-delà
des cultures des héritages des
différences de certains désaccords pour
faire ensemble
cela nous le continuerons c'est pourquoi
j'appelle toutes celles et ceux
aujourd'hui
de la social démocratie au gaullisme en
passant par les écologistes qui ne nous
ont pas encore rejoint à le faire
car depuis le début
nous n'avons qu'un parti c'est notre
pays notre volonté d'agir de porter nos
valeurs
mais associés ce sera aussi dans la
méthode
entendre davantage la minorité
permettent que la minorité comprenne
davantage la majorité que la majorité
prenne en compte les voix de la minorité
c'est infiniment difficile
et j'ai sans doute parfois échoué
mais ce combat nous devons
à chaque fois l'entreprendre
car une société ne peut pas avancer unie
et avancer au fond
si nous ne sommes pas nous tous les
dépositaires de ce respect
de cette bienveillance de cette volonté
même comme majoritaire de travailler
devrait avec les minoritaires mais de
continuer à avancer et de convaincre les
minoritaires qu'un chemin existe
c'est aussi pourquoi
c'est aussi pourquoi je veux de manière
trans partisane que nous puissions
conduire ensemble dans les 5 ans qui
viennent
une réforme institutionnelle qui
s'impose laquelle donnera justement une
plus grande place à toutes les
sensibilités politiques à tous les
courants philosophiques dans notre
assemblée je sais cher François que
c'est le combat d'une vie et donc je ne
l'abandonnerai pas
je veux un parlement plus représentatif
des pouvoirs mieux équilibrés
une souveraineté populaire mieux que
mieux reconnue et jamais limité par des
organes d'experts c'est essentiel je
veux un exécutif qui puisse trancher et
décider c'est une forme de la 5 c'est
une force de la 5e elle est
indispensable et je sais que nous sommes
quelques-uns et tenir aujourd'hui ici
aussi
au fond
je crois à même temps
déjà communisme et du girondisme allant
en même temps des fidélités gaullistes
et béarnaise
on doit pouvoir y arriver
mais tout cela c'est pour unir nous
permettre d'agir de faire et de décider
en crise
alors mes amis
toutes ces promesses
ces progrès pour chacun cette
nation de l'engagement cette unité
française
cette Europe forte tout ce que je viens
de vous décrire
mais pourtant pas une certitude
vous pensez que ce que Dylan est
impossible
pourtant
cela peut être venir ne croyez pas
les sondages ou les commentateurs qui
seraient formels
qui vous disent que c'est impossible
impensable
l'élection déjà joué que tout va bien se
passer
regardez nous regardez-vous il y a 5 ans
on le disait impossible
regardez du brexit attend d'élection ce
qui paraissait improbable et qui a pu
advenir alors je vous le dis avec
beaucoup de force ce soir rien n'est
impossible mais je ne veux ni
l'arrogance ni le défaitisme je veux la
mobilisation générale la volonté et
l'action
je n'écoute
ni ceux qui ont déjà gagné ni les
Cassandre non
mais il nous faut ensemble
relever le défi du combat le pire le
pire mes amis et d'avoir une âme
habituée des épées or nous nous sommes
habitués le danger extrémiste
aujourd'hui et d'autant plus grand que
depuis plusieurs mois à l'aider
plusieurs années la haine les vérités
alternatives se sont banalisées dans le
débat public nous nous sommes habitués
nous nous sommes habitués à voir défilé
sur certains plateaux de télévision des
auteurs antisémites d'autres racistes
maniant à longueur de journée non pas
davantage le nez sifflait pas
[Applaudissements]
par les idées avec respect
mais nous nous sommes habitués
alors contre-vérité crasse et théorie
nauséabondes nous nous sommes habitués à
voir des responsables politiques
racontez n'importe quoi sur le covid
tenir les pires discours complotistes
sur le vaccin au risque de mettre la vie
de nos compatriotes en danger
le lendemain ils sont réinvités
ils peuvent un matin sortir de l'euro le
soir revenir dans l'Europe personne
jamais ne relève leur incohérence
leur programme pourtant rune et petits
épargnants effondreraient leur pouvoir
d'achat amènent à la faillite la
retraite mais nul ne s'en est me nous
sommes habitués oui à laisser des
candidats se dire patriote tout en
faisant financer leur projet et leur
partie par l'étranger
nous nous sommes habitués à ce que
d'autres qui se réclament de Jaurès ou
de Clémenceau cesse de défendre la
laïcité et verse dans le communautarisme
encourageant contre les amants les
mouvements indigénistes et profondément
irrépublicains
nous nous sommes habitués à ce que
l'extrême droite se réclame de Charles
de Gaulle alors que tout dans son
histoire son parcours l'éloigne du
gaullisme alors que même elle est
précisément
l'extrême droite l'héritière de ceux qui
ont combattu le général
pendant tant d'années une pensée molle
celle du politiquement correct a cru
qu'on pouvait combattre l'extrême droite
en faisant des leçons de morale à ses
électeurs ça ne marche pas je n'ai
d'ailleurs jamais été partisan du
politiquement correct
mais désormais
au prétexte d'y échapper il voudrait
parfois les mêmes nous faire croire que
les contreérités que les idées les plus
choquantes que les discours au fond
légitimes le serait parce qu'ils sont
alternatives atroce et bien non non
politiquement correct mais non
politiquement abject
oui
oui un débat républicain
éclairé ou les arguments s'échangent où
les nuances sont permise ou la
dialectique permet de bâtir le bien
commun oui à ce qui est précisément une
politique exigeante oui à cette exigence
qui consiste à respecter tous nos
compatriotes quoi qu'il pense quoi qu'il
vote mais un aller les chercher allez
les convaincre
mes amis
vous l'avez compris la mobilisation
c'est maintenant
le combat
c'est le combat
du progrès contre le repli
le combat
du patriotisme et de l'Europe contre les
nationalistes
les choix d'avril sont simples au fond
vous voulez une France de la parité de
l'écologie du programme
alors aidez-nous rejoignez-nous
vous voulez une France
puissance éducative culturelle et
sportive
alors aidez-nous rejoignez-nous
vous voulez une France
puissance indépendante agricole
industrielle technologique énergétique
alors aidez-nous rejoignez-nous
vous voulez une France du Mérite du
travail
alors aidez-nous rejoignez-nous
vous voulez une France qui protège qui
assure la sécurité
nos valeurs
alors aidez-nous rejoignez-nous
vous voulez une France plus forte plus
juste dans une Europe nouvelle
alors aidez-nous
rejoignez-nous
les 10 et 24 avril la France a
rendez-vous avec son histoire ses
valeurs son destin les 10 et 24 avril
faisons ensemble le choix de l'espérance
les 10 et 24 avril
faisant ensemble le choix d'une nouvelle
époque pour la France et pour le
vive la république
et vive la France
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
on va écouter la Marseillaise
de discours
[Musique]
et voilà une Marseillaise antonée à la
toute fin sur scène après donc je disais
2h10 de discours à un très très long
discours avec deux voire trois
interluses de mémoire donc des petits
clips vidéos pour marquer des pauses
donc un discours assez long d'ailleurs
dans le chat vous êtes nombreux à
relever et à commenter cette longueur de
discours il y a Hadès qui nous dit ça
part en effet dans tous les sens dans le
chat de Figaro live ricer car 38 qui dit
difficile de faire plus décousu que son
discours et Claudius 15 qui dit quel
discours brouillon Frédéric Michaud vous
qu'est-ce que vous avez pensez de ce
discours de son seul discours finalement
discours fleuve mais qui est aussi
imposé par le fait que c'est le seul
discours du président candidat donc
nécessairement il avait on l'a bien
senti envie de s'exprimer en vie
d'utiliser
tout l'espace d'ailleurs on sait que
c'est un président qui ne tient pas
compte souvent des contraintes de temps
alors il y a eu ces deux petits
interlude on a eu effectivement
une structure du discours t'es pas
toujours évidente dans notre dans ces
longs développements qui parfois ont pu
perdre certains des des
auditeurs des personnes qui assistaient
au discours mais finalement on a bien vu
une première phase de présentation de
rappel de son de son bilan ensuite la
présentation de de 4 grandes causes et
puis une deuxième partie davantage sur
les principes un vrai retour aux
fondamentaux à la philosophie initiale
la philosophie politique initiale de
de en marche le il a rappelé le en même
temps il a rappelé l'humanisme il a
rappelé le progrès et puis une dernière
partie plus politique avec
à la fois une opposition je dirais
frontale binaire avec les extrêmes
les patrouilles
Le Pen comme un Mélenchon et puis
surtout un appel à la mobilisation
générale
au combat avec un président très très
combatif sur la forme qui a
montré plusieurs fois et et qu'il l'a
affirmé qu'il était très énergique et
donc voilà cet appel à la mobilisation à
une semaine du premier tour c'était
attendu on en parlait tout à l'heure en
préambule rien n'est fait et les
sondages montrent d'ailleurs que rien
n'est fait et et le discours du
président se termine sur sur cet appel
très fort à la mobilisation de ses
partisans
alors on retrouvera dans quelques
instants notre équipe sur place qui qui
cherche qui cherche un militant Vincent
roseron je vois que que vous êtes déjà
là vous avez suivi le meeting depuis
l'U Arena comme on dit qu'est-ce que
vous en pensez est-ce qu'il y a eu des
incidents qu'est-ce qui s'est passé vous
qui l'avez vécu de l'intérieur
oui effectivement à meeting qui a duré
un peu plus de deux heures comme vous
l'avez dit un meeting voilà et qui
Emmanuel Macron fait son fait son
premier grand meeting il y a eu des
incidents très très peu on a on a juste
entendu on a vu une banderole déployée
au bout d'un moment alors je n'ai plus
le le terme exact banderole on a eu
aussi des gens qui ont qui ont des qui
ont des barré une alarme mais bon c'est
vraiment sur le sur le côté à côté on
l'a vraiment pas beaucoup entendu sinon
un candidat qui a fait monter petit à
petit les choses sur son sur son
discours on va essayer de vous trouver
des militants qui sortent justement de
ce de ce meeting et on va essayer aussi
d'avoir François-Xavier bourreau qui a
suivi journaliste politique qui suit
Emmanuel Macron et on va essayer de
l'avoir pour qu'il nous en a tous
ressorti vu qu'elle a l'habitude de de
suivre Emmanuel Macron sur ses meetings
très bien on vous reprend dès que vous
avez quelqu'un à tout de suite Vincent
Rozon Frédéric je voudrais qu'on
revienne sur sur la scénographie de ce
midi qu'on a pas pu vraiment décrypter
avant puisqu'on a été embarqué tout de
suite
par toute cet aspect sportif on se
serait cru un petit peu à la Coupe du
monde le moment où ils ont chauffé la
salle avant que que le président
prononce son discours qu'est-ce que vous
en avez pensé est-ce que c'est novateur
est-ce que c'est déjà vu on voit bien
que là dans la dans la construction de
la scénographie et surtout avant
d'ailleurs le discours du du candidat
il y avait des références à un concert
il y avait des références à un match et
c'était un discours politique et on voit
bien que là on est dans les trois grands
forts les droits les trois grands temps
forts le concert le match le meeting
politique de communion d'une foule et et
dans la dans la conception de cet
événement
médiatico-politique il y avait
évidemment la volonté de créer quelque
chose en mélangeant ces trois
trois référence ça n'a pas du tout été
le cas dans le dans le cours du discours
du président qui est là on était
vraiment dans un discours traditionnel
avec cette nouveauté d'un président qui
qui se déplace depuis plus de 38 au sein
de cette scène en forme d'hexagone et
puis ces deux interlude donc il y avait
quand même un aspect
innovant sur sur la forme peut-être
moins innovant que les hologrammes de
Jean-Luc Mélenchon il y a il y a 5 ans
où son discours immersif en janvier mais
quand même une
renouvellement dans la forme du discours
alors je vous coupe justement on va voir
si ce militant si cette scénographie lui
a plu parce que Vincent roseron a trouvé
a trouvé quelqu'un je vous laisse la
parole
oui effectivement
du Val d'Oise qui est présent avec nous
qui a suivi ce meeting qu'on avait vous
pensez qu'on avait trouvé le candidat
Macron écoutez c'était assez
enthousiasmant il y avait déjà une foule
qui était considérable pour un sentier
tout de stratégie préparé par rapport à
ça et puis c'est un discours qui était
marqué par différentes
valeurs il y avait d'abord une forme
d'empathie de d'envie de partager
quelque chose et puis aussi un respect
il a rappelé deux trois fois le fait
qu'il fallait pas siffler ils sont juste
convaincre on a un projet qui a un
projet extrêmement large qui brosse un
avenir qui est un avis dire compliqué on
a des crises qui sont devant nous on a
des enjeux qui sont très forts moi et
qui brassent aussi un espoir
considérable et une envie de
mobilisation je pense qu'il y a aussi
dans cette forme d'humilité qu'il a
manifesté en décrivant ce qu'il voulait
faire l'envie aussi de mobiliser l'envie
aussi de dire aux uns et aux autres que
il y a pas de combats qui sont gagnées
d'avance pas trop mal qui ont perdu
d'avance non plus juste des valeurs
partagées il y a un vrai enjeu de
mobilisation à huit jours du premier
tour aujourd'hui toujours une élection
n'est jamais gagnée une élection elle se
con elle se gagne avec la conviction
avec des contacts avec tous les citoyens
avec le rapport qu'on introduit avec
chacun d'entre eux il faut les
convaincre y compris ceux qui sont pas
d'accord on en a moi je rencontre au
prix d'ailleurs dans ma silencecription
évidemment des gens qui me disent bah
voilà je suis pas d'accord je veux pas
ça je veux pas ça et bien on parle une
continuation à changer parce que ce pays
mérite qu'on est aussi des consensus sur
des questions importantes et qu'on est
aussi parfois des désaccords qui
empêchent pas d'agir très bien merci
beaucoup d'avoir été avec nous merci
brune je vous laisse en plateau je vais
essayer de vous retrouver François Gayet
Bourbon genre est Sophie Garraud qui
sera avec vous dans quelques instants en
fait signe à tout de suite Vincent ro
et donc Frédéric Michaud je voudrais
qu'on revienne un petit peu sur sur la
fin de ce discours qui était vraiment le
le volet politique oui oui enfin il
attaquait on va dire ses adversaires
sont vraiment les nommer il n'a jamais
prononcé aucun nom de ses adversaires
quel est son défi maintenant Emmanuel
Macron il ne reste plus que 6 jours on
va dire pour faire campagne sans
attaquer vraiment ses adversaires sans
vraiment les nommer comment il va un peu
tirer son épingle du jeu si l'écart se
resserre davantage dans les prochains
sondages entre Marine Le Pen et lui
alors il va y avoir encore quelques
quelques émissions politiques là
aujourd'hui effectivement c'est un c'est
un coût très important vient de jouer le
chef de l'État on verra dans quelle
mesure ça lui permet de stabiliser son
score ou ça lui permet même peut-être
d'enclencher une nouvelle dynamique tout
son appel à la fin
rejoignez-nous aidez-nous c'est aussi un
appel à ce que montage de de à la fois
des lecteurs mais aussi dans le
personnel politique davantage de
personnes contribuent à cette
mobilisation générale vous avez raison
il n'a pas cité d'adversaire et la
parler des dangers extrémistes et il y
avait cette opposition systématique
presque maniquer n pour se définir en
contraste et vraiment opposer le progrès
au repli le patriotisme et l'Europe d'un
côté versus le nationalisme le passé il
a parlé une expression forte du Grand
rabougrissement oui
des messages des messages politiques
forts il y avait aussi le rappel de du
en même temps la volonté de des
dépassements politiques il y avait aussi
des éléments de réflexion sur
nouvelle méthode nouvelle méthode pour
associer les citoyens pour
participer une vision de la France
quelques références historiques et puis
l'idée d'une France unie
au plan politique le discours était
construit et vraiment on a retrouvé les
fondamentaux du macronisme on va
retrouver tout de suite Vincent rozeron
sur place je vous laisse la parole je
vous vois vous êtes là ça y est
oui brune je suis avec Thierry et
Sherazade qui ont suivi ce meeting quand
avez-vous pensé de ce meeting d'Emmanuel
Macron un meeting fort à midi qui ramène
les valeurs qui remet les valeurs du
goût de en marche au centre c'était
c'est remotivant justement il y a un
enjeu de ce pour se mobiliser pour ce
pour ce premier tour qui est dans 8
jours c'était important de montrer que
vous étiez présent exactement c'est un
candidat engagé dynamique et qui est
vraiment envie de montrer qui est à
nouveau pour la France et pour les cinq
prochaines années
aujourd'hui est-ce que vous est-ce que
vous êtes confiant pour ce premier tour
qui a lieu dans huit jours face à face à
Marine Le Pen qui qui monte dans les
sondages confiant au premier tour oui
confiant au second tour un peu moins il
y a marine qui remonte beaucoup dans les
sondages ça fait très peur ça fait les
valeurs de la France c'est pas ça les
valeurs d'Air France pour moi c'est
Emmanuel Macron
très bien merci beaucoup en tout cas
d'avoir été présent avec nous merci
brune on va continuer à suivre cette
après-midi merci beaucoup
je vous lis toujours dans le chat vous
êtes très très nombreux toujours on a
perdu quand même la moitié des gens
effectivement puisque depuis que le
Président a terminé son discours mais
vous êtes encore plus de 5000 notamment
sur notre page Youtube
figarolive d'ailleurs je vous invite à
toujours rester courtois même si vous
n'êtes pas d'accord avec ce que dit
Emmanuel Macron Fred Baptiste qui dit le
grand rabougrissement ce terme était
fort et amusant et au KLM for Life
perlimpinpin rabougrissement mais quel
vocabulaire de ringard Frédéric Michaud
je me tourne vers vous notamment pour
faire un peu de prospective donc à dire
sur l'après aujourd'hui on donne
toujours Macron et Le Pen au second tour
est-ce que dans si ce pronostic se
confirme ça a toujours été se pronostic
de toute façon depuis le début il n'a
jamais été contredit par aucune enquête
d'opinion est-ce que le Front
républicain va s'activer cette année
alors on peut faire l'hypothèse mais
vous avez raison de rappeler que tout ça
reste encore hypothétique jusqu'à
jusqu'à jusqu'au 10 avril jusqu'au 1er
tour
on peut faire l'hypothèse que le Front
républicain continuera de fonctionner
pourquoi parce que lors des élections
régionales
on a vu à quel point il avait marché
dans la région
Provence-Alpes-Côte d'Azur si les
électeurs se mobilisent dans une
élection régionale pour empêcher
un candidat estampillé rassemblement
national qui venait de la droite Thierry
Mariani donc qui était peut-être plus
acceptable
que d'autres que d'autres candidats si
donc l'électorat régional se mobilise
fortement pour barrer l'accès à un
exécutif régional d'un candidat du
Rassemblement national on peut imaginer
qu'au niveau de la France
la mobilisation sera extrêmement forte
mais
j'observe que les hypothèses d'intention
de vote de second tour nous réalisons
faut prendre elle aussi elles aussi avec
beaucoup de avec beaucoup de distance
donc le premier tour n'a pas eu lieu le
premier tour je peux changer beaucoup de
choses psychologiquement notamment
l'écart entre les deux candidats qui
peut enclencher ou non une dynamique
pour l'un d'entre eux mais les
intentions de vote aujourd'hui
là c'est Manuel Macron a 55
54%, c'est
plus d'une dizaine de points en dessous
de 2017 donc on voit bien que l'écart
est en train de de se resserrer
peut-être que
pour rappel j'avais noté en 2017 il
avait fait 65,8% contre 34,2 pour pour
Le Pen et puis Marine Le Pen à l'époque
n'avait pas de réserve de voir
aujourd'hui on sait que 90% des
électeurs d'Éric Zemmour se
reporteraient sur elle au second tour et
donc si Eric Zemmour fait le score de
10% que dont il est crédité aujourd'hui
dans les intentions de vote il y a il y
a donc des réserves de voies il y a
aussi une partie des électeurs de
Valérie Pécresse les électeurs de
Nicolas dupontaignan et que feront les
électeurs de Mélenchon c'est aussi une
grande inconnue alors les électeurs de
Mélenchon aujourd'hui s'absiendrait
[Musique]
et un gros tiers soutiendrait
Emmanuel Macron le reste ce reporterait
effectivement sur sur Marine Le Pen mais
il va y avoir aussi une campagne de
l'entre-deux-tours et on voit bien que
on se rappelle très bien de la campagne
de 2017 et c'est un peu ce qui a
commencé la stratégie qui a commencé à
bâtir le président candidat aujourd'hui
c'est à dire d'activer ce front
républicain de de brandir le
l'épouvantail de l'extrême droite et ça
ça mobilise beaucoup et puis deuxième
élément et j'en termine par cela il va y
avoir un débat et on se rappelle aussi à
quel point le débat avait été décisif on
va dire
beaucoup de points à Marine Le Pen en
tout cas dans l'image qu'elle projetait
donc voilà on peut faire l'hypothèse
d'un front républicain même si
les les courbes d'intention de vote
pourraient se rapprocher
merci et ben justement va clore ce
meeting avec François-Xavier bourreau
qui avait ouvert le meeting tout à
l'heure avec Vincent roseron donc grand
reporter au service politique du Figaro
en charge de la couverture de l'Élysée
et donc de la couverture de la campagne
d'Emmanuel Macron je vous laisse avec
François-Xavier
oui Bruno
qui était là au début de ce meeting on
attendait un meeting avancé comme
spectaculaire est-ce que ça a été le cas
pour vous alors c'était du Macron dans
le texte sur le sur la scénographie il y
avait effectivement une grande salle
c'était plutôt réussi l'entrée le
l'ambiance ensuite sur le sur le fond
c'était du Macron dans le texte dans le
sens où il ne sait pas faire court il
n'a pas fait cours il y avait un côté
parfois un peu un peu décousu dans le
dans le discours là il commence sur une
longue partie pour défendre son bilan et
expliquer que puisqu'il a
puisqu'il a un bilan ses promesses
seront tenues il enchaîne sur son sur
son projet et il fait beaucoup de
beaucoup de digressions enfin on a eu du
mal un peu à saisir par moment le la
logique d'ensemble c'était un peu un peu
éparse mais dans une campagne courte et
resserrée il y avait peut-être la
nécessité de tout mettre dans le même
paquet si on peut dire 12 sans doute ce
discours un peu un peu dense et parfois
un peu décousu est-ce qu'il y a des
phrases ou des
ou des annonces de programme qui qui
vont rester c'est peut-être plutôt
l'appel à la mobilisation qui lance sur
la sur la fin on voit qu'il engage le la
confrontation avec alors les extrêmes
pas seulement l'extrême droite puisqu'il
vise l'extrême droite comme comme
d'habitude sa première rivale Marine Le
Pen mais aussi l'extrême gauche sans le
nommer Jean-Luc Mélenchon donc c'est cet
appel à la mobilisation auprès de ces de
ces électeurs et ses militants pour leur
dire que rien n'est joué avant le avant
le premier tour et le deuxième a
fortiori donc c'est peut-être sans doute
ça qui qu'on va retenir ou que nous on
va retenir de ce meeting l'appel à la
mobilisation alors qu'il est donné comme
étant grand favori et qui était quelque
chose qui peut engourdir ces troupes
justement niveau programme niveau
comment dire niveau orientation est-ce
qu'il y a quelque chose de nouveau ici
il a décliné le programme tel qu'il
l'avait fait dans la présentation il y a
deux semaines qui est en gros un
discours de mi-mandat en fait ou il a il
prolon les réformes qui l'engageait en
2017 il y a quelque chose de quelques
propositions en plus autour de l'école
et de la santé mais tout ça c'était
c'était déjà connu il y a pas de détails
supplémentaires
donc sur le programme en tant que tel
non mais il y a cette justification
forte enfin qu'il fait au début dire
d'expliquer que son projet 2017 c'est
aujourd'hui son bilan donc son projet de
2022 ce sera son bilan de dans 5 ans
très bien merci beaucoup François-Xavier
d'avoir été avec nous aujourd'hui merci
brune votre travail ainsi que celui
d'Arthur Bernard qui a couvert ce midi
sur le site du Figaro merci brune en
tout cas de nous avoir pris sur ce sujet
merci Vincent rozeron merci beaucoup à
Riad Bekir qui était avec vous en direct
donc dans la grande salle de Paris La
Défense Arena à Nanterre et je vais
également saluer Frédéric Michaud qui
était avec moi tout le long de ce long
meeting je rappelle que vous êtes
directeur général adjoint d'Opinion Way
et que vous comment vous avez déjà
commenté avec nous à un autre meeting
que vous saurez de nouveau parmi nous le
lendemain du 1er tour pour l'émission
point de vue donc le 11 le 11 avril
demain la campagne continue encore sur
Figaro live il y aura le meeting de
Jean-Luc Mélenchon à Toulouse et
également le meeting de Valérie Pécresse
à Porte de Versailles à suivre sur
Figaro live je remercie Benjamin Dély à
la réalisation de ce direct et Sacha
Beckermann à la modération qui était pas
forcément facile puisque vous étiez très
nombreux sur les chats merci d'ailleurs
à tous de nous avoir suivis et à très
bientôt sur Figaro live